Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, Dmitri Medvedev will unseren Kanzler Merz entführen.
Oh, die rechtliche Einordnung wird jedenfalls komplex.
Dazu müssen wir uns dann erstmal Zeit nehmen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 541 vom 6. Januar 2026.
Neues Jahr.
Hat Neujahr schon angefangen?
Ja, es ist eingeleitet worden.
Immer das Gleiche.
Ja, Kongress hat stattgefunden, also Neues Jahr.
Ja.
Und wie wir ja wissen, wird ja im neuen Jahr immer alles gut.
Wie wir an diesem Jahr ja schon gesehen haben.
Ja.
Das ist ein guter Gewände. Gleich so vom Start weg, klare Ansage,
wir werfen erstmal alles über den Haufen, was bisher als, ja,
noch als, was bisher schiefgelaufen ist.
Normen und eingespielte Muster, das wird einfach abgeräumt und wir drehen jetzt
hier einfach den Paniklevel gleich mal auf 11.
Ja. Es ist jetzt auch wirklich Panik angesagt, weil die USA brauchen halt jetzt
wirklich dringend Grönland.
Das ist...
Das haben jetzt oft genug gesagt und keiner hört hin. Also das ist schon wirklich...
Ja, ich weiß auch gar nicht. Also das ist wirklich ein traumatischer Zustand,
in dem sich die USA da befinden. Die muss unbedingt geholfen werden.
Kannst du Was ich ja sehr faszinierend finde, ist, dass sie den Maduro jetzt
bei sich vor Gericht stellen.
Also die können durchaus einen kriminellen Präsidenten vor Gericht stellen.
Ja, nur nicht den eigenen.
Hätte man nicht gedacht.
Ja, es stimmt. Also in den USA gilt sozusagen jetzt,
Gesetze gegen Kriminelle gelten nicht für die eigenen Präsidenten im eigenen
Land, aber für Präsidenten von anderen Ländern. dann im eigenen Land.
Und ich meine, das ist insofern noch eine bemerkenswerte Abkehr ihrer Politik
von 2025, wo sie ja die ganze Zeit jetzt beseelt waren, alle aus dem Land rauszuschmeißen.
Und jetzt holen sie sich die Migranten und die kriminellen Ausländer.
Die werden jetzt wieder importiert.
Das ist schon ein bemerkenswerter Wechsel. Ja,
ja. Also auf jeden Fall haben alle so ihre Schwierigkeiten, damit das eingeordnet
zu bekommen, insbesondere unsere Offiziellen.
Ja, weil die Schiss haben, dass sie jetzt nicht so auf der Liste sind.
Ja, die sind auf der Liste.
Die haben Schiss, dass die Liste jetzt abgearbeitet wird. Und das halte ich
auch mal für gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich.
Das wird auch wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner Form stattfinden.
Wer jetzt die letzten Tage unter einem Stein gelebt hat, das tun ja...
Bleibt runter!
Dann seid ihr aber hier beim falschen Kanal.
Bleibt unter eurem Stein, Leute. Er ist ein super Stein.
Falls ihr also unterm Stein gelebt habt und ihr wollt da jetzt wieder raus oder
ihr kommt da gerade raus, müssen wir halt nochmal kurz erzählen,
wovon wir reden, aber das haben wir wahrscheinlich sowieso schon alle mitbekommen.
Die USA leben jetzt sozusagen,
wieder so in den 40er, 50er Jahren und machen mal wieder was sie wollen,
vor allem mit Lateinamerika und jetzt hat es eben Venezuela getroffen in dieser,
militärisch durchaus bemerkenswerten Aktion einfach mal so eben den gut bewachten,
Präsidenten da zu extrahieren, ohne dabei,
offenbar zu eigenen Verlusten zu kommen.
Dafür hat es wohl einige Kubaner erwischt und man kann auch durchaus davon ausgehen,
dass die Kubaner so die nächsten sind auf der Liste, noch bevor sie März holen. Bevor sie März holen.
Okay, wie kommt es jetzt auf Kuba?
Naja, also es sind ja irgendwie 24 Kubaner ums Leben gekommen bei dieser Festnahme
von Maduro, weil er sich offenbar von Kubanern hat bewachen lassen.
Oh, okay.
Klassisches Diktatorspiel, weißt du, von deinen eigenen Leuten lässt du dich,
besser mal nicht bewachen, weil die sind ja im Zweifelsfall alle korrupt und
haben eigene Interessen im Kontext des Landes.
Deswegen nimmt man ja dann immer Söldner von anderen Ländern.
So wie das in Afrika immer mit russischen Söldnern gemacht wird.
Um da die Diktatoren abzusichern, hat sich also Maduro dafür Kubaner entschieden, offenbar.
Okay.
Aber das ist jetzt den Kubanern da nicht so gut bekommen.
Ja, und jetzt warten natürlich alle nur drauf, dass jetzt die USA sich auch
noch den Raul Castro irgendwie auch noch holen.
Keine Ahnung, irgendwas wird ihnen da schon einfallen.
Wieso? Hat Kuba so viel Öl?
Ja, Kuba, also ich meine Marco Rubio, der Außenminister, ist halt ja auch so
ein Exil, kubanische Familie, Heritage und die wollen halt alles haben.
Ich meine, Kuba war ja vorher schon so das US-Casino, warum sollte es das auch
nicht wieder sein? und es geht ja jetzt hier einfach um so ein imperialistisches
Spiel und da gibt es immer was zu verdienen.
Also auch aus Kuba kannst du etwas extrahieren und wenn es nur Rum und Zigarren sind.
Klar, das Öl spielt jetzt erstmal eine größere Rolle, gar keine Frage.
Das hat ja Trump auch unumwunden zugegeben.
Das ist schon alles extrem perfide und mafiös, was da abläuft und vor allem
auch so offensichtlich, weil ich meine, mittlerweile reden sie ja noch nicht
mal um den Brei drumherum, sondern sagen ganz klar, das Öl,
das läuft jetzt hier mal alles so nach uns und ihr kümmert euch mal darum,
dass wir jetzt hier das Sagen haben.
Das Öl im Boden von Venezuela, das wurde ja US-amerikanischen Firmen gestohlen.
Klar.
Ja, sagt er.
Das ist alles so absurd. Ja, muss man mal schauen.
Also kann auch gut sein, dass die USA sich da einfach ein bisschen übernehmen,
weil wie sie jetzt ein Land unterjochen wollen,
wo sie eigentlich nur davor lagern, das wird nochmal ganz interessant werden
zu sehen, aber sie können natürlich jetzt dieses Land auf viele Arten und Weisen
erpressen und wenn es nur eine Seeblockade ist.
Und es ist davon auszugehen, dass die ohnehin schon beklagenswerte Situation,
humanitäre Situation für viele Venezuelaner jetzt sich nicht unbedingt verbessern wird.
Und das ist auch alles sehr beunruhigend.
Obwohl die Empfängerin des Nobelpreises jetzt Trump sogar schon ihren Nobelpreis angeboten hat.
Friedensnobelpreis.
Ja genau, Friedensnobelpreis. Könnte er ja haben.
Ja, es ist alles so.
Es ist so ein absurdes Tarn, es ist fast überhaupt nicht mehr zu fassen.
Und dementsprechend rudern auch unsere europäischen Politoberhäupter alle ganz
ordentlich mit den Armen, weil das Hirn gar nicht mehr weiß, wo es langen soll.
Allen voran unser Bundeskanzler, der ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten hat mit der Einordnung.
Ja, wobei da den meisten Leute so vom Fach, die jetzt so die sagen halt,
nee, das ist gar nicht so schwer einzuordnen, das ist völkerrechtswidrig.
Du kannst nicht einfach, also ich bin ja auch Laie auf dem Gebiet,
aber mir leuchtet das intuitiv zum Beispiel auch ein,
dass man sich irgendwann mal darauf geeinigt hat, dass man nicht einfach in
ein anderes Land fliegen und das Regierungsoberhaupt entführen kann.
Also ich meine, das haben die USA schon mal gemacht, so ist das jetzt nicht.
Nee, aber da braucht man auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, da brauchst du irgendwie,
also mir leuchtet schon ein, dass man, oder ich würde vermuten,
dass man versucht hat, dafür bestimmte Regeln zu formulieren.
Das gibt es ja auch. Das ist halt die UN-Charta, aber auf die scheißten halt
die USA wie alle anderen Großmächte ja ohnehin schon.
Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass sich jetzt China oder Russland groß dran halten würden.
Von daher ist das ja eh alles nur noch so eine Farce, was auf UN-Ebene abläuft.
Weil, ich meine, die UN war jetzt nie sonderlich gut bezahnt,
aber war zumindest in der Lage,
halbwegs so einen Grundkonsens herzustellen, an den sich alle so halbwegs gehalten haben.
Aber davon sind wir jetzt mittlerweile leider weit entfernt die Russen haben
auf jeden Fall jetzt auch nicht so eine gute Zeit gehabt mit der Nummer weil
damit fällt ihre wenn ich das richtig sehe,
vorletzte Bastion in Lateinamerika,
je nachdem wie man ihr Verhältnis zu Brasilien jetzt noch so bewerten möchte,
fällt damit weg Und vor allem halt auch ein wichtiger Verbündeter im Rahmen der OPEC.
Also wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass diese neue Situation bedeutet,
dass Venezuela politisch jetzt kaltgestellt ist und dass in irgendeiner Form
die Amerikaner ihre ganze militärische Macht dazu nutzen werden, die.
Die Möglichkeit von Venezuela, sich selbst zu regieren, so weit einzuschränken, wie es irgendwie geht.
Völlig unklar, wie das militärisch da weitergeht. Völlig unklar,
wie sich das jetzt innerhalb des Landes, innenpolitisch weiterentwickelt.
Aber es ist vollkommen klar, dass der russische Einfluss ist quasi tot.
Auch ihr Militärbeitrag hat mal wieder nichts gebracht, wie schon in Syrien
und dementsprechend stehen sie halt doof da und das Einzige,
was sie halt noch können, ist rumkeifen,
allen voran halt Dmitri Medvedev,
der ehemalige Stand-in für Putin, als der mal sich noch an die Verfassung gehalten
hat, die russische und mal so zweimal ausgesetzt hat mit Präsident sein.
Mittlerweile ist er ja sozusagen nur noch so eine Kaifbacke,
die die ganze Zeit dumme Kommentare von sich gibt und jetzt will er März entführen.
Ja, bring it on, sag ich nur.
Ob Russland reicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt so schnell bemerken würden, wenn er weg ist.
Also ich würde mir erst mal Zeit nehmen, das zu bewerten. einzuordnen.
Man darf ja auch immer so schnell schüssen.
Das ist komplex.
Das ist ein komplexes Feld.
Da muss man erstmal abwarten. Da sollte man jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht unnötig
eskalieren, so eine Situation.
Oder übermolkieren oder so.
Nee, nein. Nein. Nein.
Genauso braucht man nicht überzureagieren, wenn die USA mal ein paar Einreiseverbote verhängen.
Wir hatten ja vor einigen Sendungen schon darüber gesprochen,
dass der internationale Strafgerichtshof zu Open Desk wechselt.
Nicht ganz freiwillig, weil sie aufgrund der Sanktionen gegen den Chefermittler
eben auch Microsoft Office nicht mehr nutzen können.
Ganz so schlimm hat es Thierry Breton und Annalena von Hodenberg und Josephine Ballon,
die bei also der, sorry, ich fang nochmal von vorne an, Vielen Dank.
Den früheren EU-Kommissar Thierry Breton und die beiden Vertreterinnen von HateAid,
Annalena von Hodenberg und Josephine Ballon, hat es nicht ganz so hart getroffen.
Die dürften erstmal nur nicht mehr einreisen, genauso wie zwei weitere britische Aktivistinnen.
Und was interessant ist, dass es sehr nah fällt an die X-Strafe wegen des Verstoßes
gegen den Digital Services Act.
Und der Thierry Breton hat den entscheidend mitgeprägt. Und HateAid waren im
Kontext des DSA Trusted Flagger.
Das heißt, wenn die einen Inhalt gefleckt haben,
wurden sie quasi priorisiert behandelt und wurde einfach erstmal grundsätzlich
vertraut und dann eine Löschung dieses Inhaltes herbeigeführt.
Jetzt kann man darüber geteilter Meinung sein,
ob das gut oder schlecht oder richtig oder falsch ist und was Hate-Aid gemacht
hat und was der DSA macht und ob diese Rolle spielen sollte oder nicht.
Das ist halt eine gesetzmäßige, EU-weite Durchsetzung und Umsetzung von Gesetz
gewesen, was da stattgefunden hat.
Das heißt, die Personen von HateAid haben jetzt nicht irgendetwas,
getan, was in irgendeiner Weise weißt du, es war illegal wäre.
Nein, die sind einer rechtlich vorgesehenen Rolle gefolgt.
Aber das findet jetzt zum Schutz der Meinungsfreiheit dar, weil die Arbeit von
Hate-Ad und die gesamte EU-Regulierung, der Digital Services Act insbesondere, eben Zensur sind.
Und ja, deswegen ja, dürfen die jetzt nicht mehr in die USA.
So, zack. Und dann denkst du, okay, das ist aber jetzt wirklich ein bisschen übertrieben.
Also Microsoft dürfen sie noch nutzen, glaube ich. Sie sind jetzt nicht auf einer Sanktionsliste.
Das ist nämlich die rote Hilfe. Nicht direkt die rote Hilfe, sondern.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Sanktionslisten der USA und es gibt auch unterschiedliche Sanktionslisten,
denen auf die Banken achten müssen.
Eine, die sehr häufig zitiert wird, ist die AMCTF,
das ist die Anti-Money-Laundering-Counter-Terrorism-Financing-Liste.
Und wenn du Organisationen oder Menschen, die da draufstehen,
da musst du als Bank enorm vorsichtig sein, dass du aktiv prüfst,
dass du denen keinen Zahlungsverkehr ermöglichst,
Und wenn es dir passiert, dass du unmittelbare Konsequenzen rausziehst,
weil du im Prinzip den Ausschluss vom internationalen Zahlungsverkehr riskierst,
wenn du das fahrlässig oder wissentlich dagegen verstößt.
Und...
Jetzt ist Folgendes passiert, es gibt einen Verein, der heißt Rote Hilfe,
den gibt es schon sehr lange, ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie lange es die Rote Hilfe schon gibt,
die sich zum Ziel setzt, Linke, die von staatlicher Repression betroffen sind, zu schützen.
Den nehme ich mit in der Regel juristischem Beistand.
Im Prinzip so ein Fonds zur Verteidigung von Menschen,
die im Rahmen von Demonstrationen oder linker Aktivität und Aktivismus in Gerichtsverfahren
gelandet sind, die werden dann von der Roten Hilfe unterstützt.
Und da man, wenn man sich beispielsweise im Bereich des Antifaschismus,
Antirassismus oder Klimagerechtigkeit und Ähnlichem engagiert,
auch gerne mal im Rahmen einer Demonstration oder im Rahmen von anderen Protestformen
mit Recht und Gesetz in Konflikt gerät,
namentlich in Form der Polizei, die einen einfach niederknüppelt und dann sagt,
das war Widerstand gegen die Staatsgewalt oder auch weil man bei der Rot über
die Ampel gegangen ist oder bei Rot über die Ampel gegangen und dann sitzen
geblieben ist und dadurch quasi den Verkehr.
Eingeschränkt hat oder sonstige Ordnungswidrigkeiten begangen hat,
findet man sich eben auch mal in einer Situation vor Gericht wieder und quasi
diesen Menschen eine Unterstützung zu leisten ist Aufgabe oder Zielsetzung der Roten Hilfe.
Und die Rote Hilfe hat mitgeteilt bekommen, dass ihr das Konto gekündigt wurde.
Bei der GLS-Bank und bei einer Sparkasse in Göttingen.
Und die haben kein Konto mehr.
Und das ist ziemlich, sie kriegen natürlich mitgeteilt, dass es noch ein bisschen dauert.
So, jetzt hat die Rote Hilfe also sehr zeitnah keine Konten mehr.
Und das ist, also wenn du kein Konto mehr hast, das ist natürlich halt wirklich,
also das ist halt wirklich dann dein Ende, ne, weil du kannst ja dann nicht
mehr im Zahlungsverkehr teilnehmen, die haben ja auch Geld auf ihren Konten,
die gehen ja, wenn die Sachen fördern, wenn die Spenden entgegennehmen,
das ist im Prinzip das.
Das... Ja, oder Gehälter bezahlen.
Also genau, du kannst einfach, diese Organisation könnte, wenn das so bleibt,
nicht mehr weiterarbeiten.
Übrigens, wir sprechen viel über die Rote Hilfe. Das gleiche Schicksal ereilte
in der gleichen Woche die Konten der Deutschen Kommunistischen Partei sowie
einer Gruppe mit dem Namen Anarchist Black Cross.
Es gibt noch mehr Gruppen, also ich meine es ist irgendwie, aber die sind glaube
ich nicht alle öffentlich.
Also es wird von der GLS Bank auch in ihrer Pressemitteilung darüber gesprochen,
dass es halt wahrscheinlich noch ein paar mehr waren.
Nach meiner Kenntnis ist noch nicht vollständig aufgeklärt, was da genau los
ist und auf welcher Basis das passiert.
Aber die GLS-Bank schreibt in ihrer wahrscheinlich sehr hastig geschriebenen
ersten Stellungnahme so etwas wie, ja,
wir haben halt Sorgfaltspflichten und bei Organisationen, die vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet werden, müssen wir ohnehin genau hinschauen.
Das ist bei der Roten Hilfe der Fall, klar, weil der Verfassungsschutz betrachtet
ja progressive Kräfte als verfassungsfeindlich.
Und wenn die Rote Hilfe denen bei der Regelung ihrer juristischen Auseinandersetzung hilft,
dann ist das natürlich linksradikal und staatsfeindlich aus Sicht des Verfassungsschutzes. Schutz ist.
Frage mich, wann der Verfassungsschutz mal darauf kommt, dass Strafrechtsanwälte,
weißt du, was die machen?
Die helfen Straftätern. Da müsste man vielleicht auch nochmal was,
da müsste man vielleicht auch nochmal bei.
Da müsste man auch nochmal bei. Ja, überleg mal, die helfen Straftäter und nennen
sich Organe der Rechtspflege.
Das ist einfach...
Also da müsste auch nochmal einer gucken, ja. So, die...
Die rote Hilfe musste eben ohnehin genau hingeschaut werden.
Und dann sagen sie im nächsten Satz so, ja und außerdem gibt es Gruppierungen,
die auf Sanktionslisten stehen.
Und es gibt eben so etwas wie Antifa Ost oder sonst was, was potenziell auf
solchen Sanktionslisten steht.
Und was ich aus diesem Text herauslese,
Das stattgefunden haben könnte, dass die GLS-Bank ohnehin bei der Roten Hilfe
hingeschaut hat und dann eventuell im Rahmen von Gerichtsverfahren Spenden gesammelt
wurden zur Unterstützung von Menschen,
die beschuldigt waren, Teil einer Organisation zu sein, die unter Umständen
eben auf dieser MA-CTF oder einer anderen Sanktionsliste stand.
Und die Stellungnahme der GLS Bank liest sich zumindest so, als hätten sie das
hier proaktiv und aus eigenem Antrieb getan.
Gleichzeitig ist die, nach meiner Laieneinschätzung, die Situation einer Bank so, dass sie,
wenn sie wissentlich gegen quasi die Ziele dieser Listen verstößt,
damit rechnen muss, dass sie vom Zahlungsverkehr komplett ausgeschlossen wird.
Das heißt, es wäre dann eben auch als existenzielles Risiko für die Bank zu
werten, wenn sie es nicht macht.
So zumindest lese und verstehe ich die Stellungnahme der GLS Bank.
Ja, ich habe einfach Schiss, dass sie selber zugemacht werden.
Ja, ja, aber das ist ungefähr so, also die haben die Reaktion gezeigt,
wie wenn du jetzt in Deutschland einen Verein gründest oder ein Konto gründest
und sagst, ich sammle jetzt hier Spenden für Al-Qaida.
Und dann gehen da die ganze Zeit Überweisungsbelege ein.
Hier Spende Januar 2020 so und so für Al-Qaida oder Islamischer Staat.
Da muss eine Bank dann eben auch im Zweifelsfall sagen, so tut mir leid das
können wir so nicht machen so sind die jetzt hier mit der Roten Hilfe umgegangen und mit der DKP, die,
eine Partei ist die offensichtlich in Deutschland existiert und existieren darf,
damit im Zweifelsfall nicht verfassungsfeindlich ist, weil ich glaube da würden
wir ja genau hinschauen wenn es verfassungsfeindliche Bestrebungen in Parteien gäbe oder nicht.
Das wird sofort geprüft.
Das würde geprüft werden eigentlich. Insofern würde ich vermuten,
dass hier die Prüfung stattgefunden hat.
Ja, genau. Und Antifa Ost wurde eben als Terror auf eine Terrorliste genommen.
Aber das ist jetzt wirklich meine Spekulation. Nach meiner Kenntnis hat sich
die GLS Bank noch nicht wirklich vollständig erklärt.
So und das ist jetzt, also da geht es halt wirklich ans Eingemachte,
weil wenn die USA irgendjemand auf eine Liste schreiben und diese Leute dann
in Deutschland ihre Bankkonten verlieren.
Dann ist was kaputt dann naja.
Dann haben wir jetzt wirklich mit einem Ausmaß an Einflussnahme auch wirklich
innenpolitischer Einflussnahme zu tun was glaube ich auch jetzt jede langsam
erkennen sollte im Ausmaß,
der Besorgniserregung, die damit einhergeht.
Ja, es ist ein Skandal. Ich meine, es geht überhaupt nicht und es kann einfach
nicht sein, dass sich Europa von den Amerikanern mal eben,
irgendwelche Organisationen kaputt gemacht werden und de facto reden wir ja
davon, die hier sich vollständig im legalen Bereich bewegen.
Ja, aber sowas auch. Ja, bis es anders bewiesen ist.
Man kann ja sein, dass die alle ganz böse sind und nach Lulu riechen,
aber das ist ja dann sozusagen, naja, aber selbst wenn es so wäre,
dann, ich meine, die AfD hat ja ihre Konten auch noch.
Und von daher sehe ich da, ehrlich gesagt, überhaupt keinerlei Anlass für Automatismen,
davon reden wir hier, ja.
Die Amerikaner setzen jemand auf eine Liste und es gibt keinerlei Überprüfung,
es gibt keinerlei Barriere, es gibt keinerlei Verhinderung.
Hier in irgendeiner Form eine Klärung vorzunehmen, einen Vorbehalt wahrzunehmen.
Vielleicht ist es den Amerikanern mittlerweile auch egal.
Es ist einfach nur die Drohung, ihr wollt irgendwas mit Amerika machen?
Und ihr tut irgendwas, was uns nicht gefällt, dann seid ihr raus.
Also das ist einfach die einfachste Form von Zensur und politischer Unterdrückung,
vollkommen durchautomatisiert über das Bankensystem.
Und das ist natürlich etwas, das muss diskutiert werden auf europäischer Ebene, weil das geht nicht.
Das ist einfach ein vollkommen unangemessener und in kürzester Zeit zu diskutierender
und zu entscheidender Fall.
Hier muss Europa einfach handeln. Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht nur in diesem Fall so.
Nochmal an die Leute, die gerade aus dem Stein rauskommen. Wir haben da gerade
einen, naja, jenseits des Atlantik ist man uns nicht mehr so wohlgesonnen.
Und das ist ja eine Position, die, sagen wir mal,
eigentlich schon seit zwei Jahren sich, oder spätestens mit dem Wiedererstarken
der Trump-Bewegung und dann spätestens natürlich mit seiner Präsidentschaft
irgendwie relativ klar sein sollte, dass also hier ein Problem entsteht.
Aber leider sind wir in Europa ja derzeit nicht in der Lage,
diese Einigung, die wir auf dem Papier haben, auch zu leben.
Und ja, das schwächt natürlich unsere Position hier wie auch in der Situation mit dem Krieg.
Wir sind wirklich in einer...
Also das wirklich Dramatische, was sich ja hier eben offenbart, ist, dass es halt geht.
Das kannst du mit Europa machen, das kannst du mit Deutschland machen. und.
Ja, ich kann das ja wir machen ja selten da mal eine Buchempfehlung aber ich
setze mich gerade mit diesem Thema auseinander, weil der Holger Stark kürzlich
ein Buch veröffentlicht hat,
mit dem Titel, wie heißt es Das erwachsene Land in Deutschland ohne Amerika
eine historische Chance. Was macht er in dem Buch?
Er stellt im Prinzip so dar das Verhältnis, eigentlich das Nachkriegsverhältnis
von USA zu Europa und natürlich dann insbesondere Deutschland.
Holger Stark war unter anderem Autor des Enthüllungsartikels 2013,
dass die USA das Handy von Angela Merkel abgehört haben.
Er ist aber gleichzeitig jemand, der in West-Berlin aufgewachsen ist und sehr
Amerika-positiv sozialisiert wurde und auch als Korrespondent sehr lange in Washington war.
Und der zeichnet das ganz gut nach, wie sich das über die George W.
Zeit, über die Obama-Zeit und so weiter.
Entwickelt hat und dass die Ursprünge halt auch schon sehr viel früher liegen,
aber zeigt eben auch, dass,
ja, Deutschland insbesondere, aber auch der größere Teil von Europa sich eben
sehr, sehr lange irgendwie so unter den ja, unterm Flügel der USA bequem gemacht haben,
und das geht eben so lange gut, wie die wie die USA da Bock drauf haben,
und jetzt haben die halt mal, jetzt weht da ein bisschen anderer Wind und da
herrscht jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr Gier.
Und die herrschte schon immer.
In anderen Teilen der Welt hat man schon lange nicht mehr besonders positiv auf die USA geblickt.
Das gehört ja auch zur Wahrheit dazu.
Und jetzt richten die ihren Zorn eben halt mal in unsere Richtung.
Ich meine, wenn du dir diese Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz Rede anhörst und
so, da zeichnet sich ja jetzt so, das fügt sich ja alles zu einem Bild zusammen,
wo wir eigentlich jetzt so alle zwei Wochen oder was irgendeine vollkommen irrsinnige
Grenzüberschreitung dulden.
Das ist das, was wir, ja, und Und das werden wir auch noch länger tun,
weil wir eben nichts haben, was man dagegenhalten kann.
Und weil sich die Europäische Union...
Irgendwie damit noch nicht so ganz zurechtfindet.
Naja, ich meine, wir hätten schon was dagegen zu halten. So ist es nicht. Aber es würde halt...
Es wird schmerzhaft.
Es wird sehr schmerzhaft werden. Und dazu ist halt das Land und Europa an sich
noch nicht so richtig bereit, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt riskieren wir mal hier
unseren Wohlstand und unseren Modus operandi,
weil wir jetzt mal harte Kante fahren gegen die USA. Weil es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass die USA...
Nicht auch uns brauchen würden. Nur benehmen sie sich halt gerade nur so,
als würden ja alle immer nur, das ist ja auch so Trumps These.
Alle bedienen sich hier bei uns und wir werden ja ausgenutzt und deswegen die Zölle und so weiter.
Aber es sind halt einfach alles nur Erpressungsmethoden, um sein mafiöses,
korruptes Buddy-System mit Geld zu versorgen.
Und was noch viel dramatischer ist, ist natürlich die dahinterliegende Denke,
dass jetzt die Welt sich quasi so in drei große Einflusssphären aufteilt.
In die russische, in die chinesische und in die US-amerikanische.
Und dann will er halt irgendwie den amerikanischen Kontinent für sich haben
und Europa ist ihm so ein bisschen egal.
Also zumindest sagen sie das, ihnen ist das natürlich nicht egal.
Sie möchten gerne, dass hier auch alles voll ist mit Cronies,
weil die wissen natürlich schon, dass hier auch wichtige wirtschaftliche Ressourcen sind,
die auf die USA angewiesen ist, aber es soll halt einfach mal alles nach ihrer
Pfeife laufen und alle potenziellen Deals mit leicht auszubeutenden Ressourcen,
Deswegen geht es ja vor allem in diesen Rohstoffbereichen immer so zur Sache.
Das soll dann halt auch eine unmittelbare Einnahmequelle sein.
So wie es die Russen halt im Prinzip auch waren.
Im Prinzip die Adaption der russischen Methode,
des putischen Staatsverständnisses auf die USA und irgendwie schafft es die
amerikanische Bevölkerung immer noch nicht dem einen Riegel vorzuschieben und
es ist auch gerade noch ein bisschen unklar, ob das gelingen wird.
Die Chance besteht, aber noch ist es halt nicht so weit.
Also gut, ich habe dir das Buch ja empfohlen.
Ich sehe nicht, dass es da noch eine Chance gibt, dass sich hier etwas ändert.
Das wird noch schlimmer werden, bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher.
Dass sich vor was ändert, in den USA was ändert oder in Europa was ändert?
In Europa wird sich so oder so etwas ändern?
Die Frage ist eigentlich nur, wie lange brauchen wir bis wir die,
bis wir bereit sind, das auch mitzugestalten, was sich hier ändert.
Im Moment wird ganz Europa da eigentlich hin und her getreten und es ist wehrlos
und da muss man halt mal schauen, ab wann hier irgendjemand mal erkennt,
dass es so oder so schmerzhaft wird,
und dass man diesen Schmerz jetzt höchstens noch gestalten kann.
So würde ich das eigentlich,
sehen. Aber wir sind ja, wenn wir immer so viel über Themen reden,
die nicht mit Netzpolitik zu tun haben, dann kriegen wir Ärger.
Deswegen, ich wollte eigentlich meine schöne Holger-Stark- Überleitung machen,
denn das nächste kleine Thema, auf das wir eingehen, ist auch wieder ein Holger-Stark-Thema.
Und es hat auch genau mit der 2013er Enthüllung zu tun.
Nämlich Ausspähen unter Freunden geht ja gar nicht.
Sagte damals Angela Merkel als bekannt wurde, dass ihr Handy abgehört wurde von den USA.
Und die, ich glaube damals war so ein bisschen die Erklärung,
es war so im Rahmen des Snowden- Enthüllungen, wo es dann so diese Listen gab
und da steht man irgendwie die Handynummer von Angela Merkel drauf.
Dann war sie enttäuscht auf einer persönlichen und auf einer professionellen
Ebene und dann war das natürlich ein großer.
Also wirklich ein sehr, sehr großes Thema, ehrlich gesagt, auch viel größer,
als ich damals dachte, dass es werden würde.
Weil ich mir irgendwie dachte so, naja, also ich meine, das ist eigentlich das
geringste Problem. Ich erwarte ja im Prinzip von einem Geheimdienst,
dass er seine Arbeit macht und gefährlichst die Staatsoberhaupt abhört.
Also würde ich jetzt erwarten.
Würde ich zum Beispiel auch vom BND erwarten, der genau das auch gemacht hat.
Denn der bis 2014 hörte der Bundesnachrichtendienst über Jahre Barack Obama ab.
Und zwar immer dann, wenn er an Bord der Air Force One telefoniert hat.
Das kam jetzt raus, dass 2014, warum hat es aufgehört?
Weil da die Süddeutsche Zeitung berichtet hat, dass die damalige US-Außenministerin
Hillary Clinton abgehört worden war.
Und dann hat Peter Altmaier, Kanzleramtschef, verfügt, das zu stoppen.
Und wusste aber nicht, dass der BND auch Obama abgehört hat.
Und dann haben wir der BND quasi in dem Rahmen dann so, ja, okay,
wenn die nicht wollen, dass wir Hillary Clinton abhören, dann hören wir mal beim Barack auch auf.
Also, ausspähen unter Freunden geht echt überhaupt nicht, findet auch Barack Obama.
Tja, hätten sie mal besser zugehört weiter. Hätten sie vielleicht mehr verstanden von den USA.
Ja, ja gut, aber da hätte das immer noch der BND das auch verstehen müssen.
Wir sehen also jetzt, wenn wir jetzt mal auf die allgemeine Großwetterlage schauen,
ein Land, USA,
das gerade in diesem Bereich der Informationstechnologien und Netze einen großen Teil dessen,
was hier unser ganzes Netz und Internet und Social Net und Office und E-Mail und so weiter bestimmt,
haben die gebaut und betreiben es,
sind damit, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall in unseren Bereichen des Netzes absolut
einflussreich und maßgebend.
Sind inzwischen so stark in dieser Vernetzungsmacht,
dass sie dem internationalen Strafgerichtshof die Kommunikation abdrehen,
dass sie, wenn man irgendwie Twitter eine Strafe gibt,
die Leute sanktionieren, die
das Gesetz auf EU-Ebene koordiniert und geschrieben haben und diejenigen,
die an dessen Ausumsetzung arbeiten und zwar nicht als irgendwie staatliche
Bedienstete, sondern als NGOs.
Sie setzen politische Gruppen auf Sanktionslisten, die daraufhin ihre Konten verlieren.
Die fliegen in ein anderes Land, entführen den Präsidenten. Die lassen irgendwie
Russland relativ problemlos die Ukraine
überfallen, die eigentlich mal Sicherheitsgarantien bekommen hatte.
Klammer auf, macht Deutschland auch.
Und wir müssen uns mal so langsam fragen, naja, wenn das jetzt so weitergeht,
und es ist ja jetzt nicht so, als würde der Trump den Eindruck machen,
als würde er so ungefähr sagen, ach ja, okay, jetzt bin ich fertig.
Das war jetzt gut, jetzt habe ich alles gemacht, was ich wollte,
sondern sind ja gerade erst am Beginn, dass sie diese Macht, die sie haben,
jetzt nicht mehr nur still und soft durch,
ja, einfach nur dadurch, dass sie sie haben.
Nutzen, sondern dass sie die jetzt auch aktiv einsetzen.
Und zwar nicht zu knapp und,
auf ziemlich besorgniserregende Weise. Und das berührt ja nun mal auch so etwas wie,
unser Social Network Leben, unsere E-Mails, unsere Messenger,
wo wir all das irgendwie auf X und Facebook und Amazon abbilden.
Vielleicht auch unsere Domains.
Genau. Und eigentlich einigen wenigen sehr, sehr großen Konzernen eine ungeheure
Macht über essentielle Teile des gesellschaftlichen Lebens geben.
Und das ist echt nicht mehr witzig.
Und aus diesem Grunde haben wir dann auf dem 39C3,
mit vielen anderen Organisationen zusammen, aber insbesondere durch Marc-Uwe
Klingen und mit Marc-Uwe Klingen den Digital Independence Day ausgerufen.
Du musst dann aber kurz sagen, wer mit wir jetzt gemeint ist.
Wir, der Chaos Computer Club.
Okay. Nicht Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Nein, doch wir jetzt auch, Logbuch Netzpolitik auch.
Was?
Der CCC.
Ziehst mich da mit rein.
Viele weitere Organisationen haben gesagt, wir machen Digital Independence Day
und zwar machen wir den monatlich.
Und Digital Independence Day funktioniert so.
Man verlässt eine der Big-Tech-Plattformen und gibt damit an und zeigt, dass es anders geht.
Sei es, ob man jetzt mal langsam WhatsApp durch einen vernünftigen Messenger ersetzt,
einen, der quasi vielleicht sogar für Bezahlung betrieben wird und das Ziel
hat, glückliche Kunden zu haben und nicht nur glückliche Kunden zu haben,
um deren soziale Netze zu mappen.
Oder man verlässt Facebook.
Das dürfte am einfachsten sein. Ich meine, das nutzt ja kaum noch jemand.
X oder Instagram und bewegt sich in Richtung der besseren Alternative.
Man kann auch seine E-Mail mal von Google Mail wegziehen zu einem anderen E-Mail-Anbieter.
Und man macht das einfach mal so ein bisschen in Ruhe.
Und vor allem achtet man darauf, dass die Leute mitkommen.
Denn das ist ja das, was die Macht dieser Konzerne ausmacht.
Ich muss sagen, bei all dem finde ich immer noch die sogenannten sozialen Netzwerke am wichtigsten.
Es ist wirklich ein Unding, dass wir den größeren Teil unserer politischen Diskussionen
und politischen Meinungsbildung und freien Austausch zu Themen auf zentralen
Plattformen von Unternehmen abhalten,
die diese Plattformen betreiben,
um mehr über uns zu lernen und uns Werbung zu zeigen.
Oder sogar direkt die politische Meinung zu beeinflussen, die dort geäußert wird.
Und dann genau hingehen und sagen, jetzt machen wir mal direkt politische Meinung.
Dann werden sie gekauft von Elon Musk und der sagt, pass auf,
die politische Meinung ist jetzt folgende.
Ich habe es jetzt nochmal angeschaut, meine Reichweite bei Twitter ist ein Bruchteil.
Es ist wirklich ein Bruchteil von der Reichweite, die ich da mal hatte.
Mit dem Elon Musk ist jetzt da, ist was vorbei.
Das wird potenziell damit zusammenhängen, dass ich Inhalte verbreite,
die jetzt nicht unbedingt zu Elon Musks Weltbild passen.
Es kann eventuell auch damit zu tun haben, dass ich mich selbstverständlich
weigere, dem Geld zu geben.
Aber wenn man sich anschaut, was für ein inhaltliches Erlebnis Twitter vor dem
Kauf war und kurz danach wurde, dann sieht man, wie viel Einfluss über quasi
die Kontrolle dieser Plattform herrscht.
Denn was man da gezeigt kriegt, ist ja nicht irgendwie das, was man bestellt hat.
Du folgst so und so vielen Leuten und auf einmal wird deine Timeline priorisiert.
Bei Facebook schon immer das Geschäftsmodell gewesen, wenn du da irgendwie mehr
Leute erreichen möchtest, dann wird dir gesagt, ach guck mal hier,
du hast eine Facebook-Seite, der folgen 10.000 Leute, du hast gerade einen Post
gemacht, den haben jetzt 1.000 gesehen.
Willst du das dir noch 500 sehen, schmeißt einfach Geld ein,
dann zeigen wir den Leuten. und es ist es ist so und es war schon immer absoluter
Irrsinn das überhaupt zu akzeptieren.
Und auf jeden Fall Digital Independence Day, kurz DIT, da machen wir das.
Und was ich mir so immer dabei gedacht habe, ist, das Problem ist eigentlich
nicht, was weiß ich, dir einen Mastrodon-Account zu machen oder Signal oder
Threema oder Matrix oder weiß der Geier zu installieren.
Das Problem ist eigentlich, die anderen Leute damit hinzubringen.
Dass du halt das, was du an Kommunikations- und Informationsbedürfnissen hast,
da auch abbilden kannst.
Und das funktioniert eben nur, wenn man seine Leute mitbringt und mit denen darüber redet.
Und das haben wir also interessanterweise, genauso haben wir es ja mit Facebook
und WhatsApp auch gemacht.
Also das ist ja auch so gewesen, dass irgendwann einmal irgendjemand zu einem
kam und gesagt hat, ey, installier mal WhatsApp.
Und dann hat man irgendwann jemanden getroffen, der es nicht hatte.
Der hat gesagt, installier mal WhatsApp, kostet die SMS nicht mehr 19 Cent.
Oder was so ein Ding gekostet hat.
Und das müssen wir jetzt einfach mal mit was machen, was vielleicht nicht von
einzelnen Milliardären kontrolliert wird,
die ihr Fähnlein in den Wind halten oder vielleicht tatsächlich irgendwelche Ziele verfolgen, die,
sagen wir mal, jetzt nicht unbedingt mit liberaler Demokratie und freiheitlich-demokratischer
Grundordnung zu tun haben.
Und das kann man eigentlich relativ einfach daran erkennen, wenn man sich überlegt,
womit verdienen die Konzerne denn ihr Geld?
Weil das ist ja das, was sie im Zweifelsfall am besten tun werden.
Okay, was macht Facebook? Ah, die verdienen ihr Geld mit Werbung.
Was macht Google? Okay, die verdienen ihr Geld mit Werbung. So, was macht...
Was macht, keine Ahnung, irgendeine Mastodon-Instanz? Im Zweifelsfall verdient
ihr Geld dadurch, dass Leute dahin spenden für den Betrieb dieser Infrastruktur.
Was macht Signal? Verdienen ihr Geld auf jeden Fall nicht mit Werbung,
sondern mit spendenden Nutzerinnen oder zahlenden Nutzerinnen,
es gibt wirklich eine ganze Reihe an wirklich sehr viel besseren Alternativen,
wo die Interessen aligned sind.
Wo ich weiß, diejenigen, denen ich meine Daten da anvertraue,
oder von denen ich meine Aufmerksamkeit steuern lasse, die sind diesem Ziel,
was ich hier verfolge, wohlgesonnen.
Die haben das auch, die möchten das und nur das, weil damit verdienen die ihr
Geld. Und das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Test.
Ja, also ein schönes Ziel, aber es wird schwierig werden.
Genau deswegen monatlich und in kleinen Schritten und der Aufruf darüber zu reden.
Ich finde zum Beispiel nicht, dass es, also natürlich ist es schwierig,
dass, was weiß ich, Deutschland oder europaweit WhatsApp abgelöst wird.
Aber der einzelne Wechselschritt, und das merke ich jetzt auch in den Gesprächen
und Interviews dazu, er wird immer so unglaublich dramatisch wahrgenommen.
In Wirklichkeit installieren die Leute sich jeden Tag beim Kacken irgendeine neue App.
Und nutzen die. Und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Abnehm-Apps die Leute auf ihrem Handy allein haben.
Und sich eine mehr zu installieren, wird ja jetzt wirklich nicht zum Drama führen.
Das Entscheidende ist, die Leute dahin mitzunehmen. Das ist also viel eher als
ein technisches Unterfangen.
Ist es halt ein soziales Unterfangen, zu überlegen, wo bilde ich diesen Bedarf
ab, wie möchte ich das machen, mit wem rede ich da drüber, wie kriegen wir das hin.
Ich zum Beispiel lebe seit, ich weiß nicht wie vielen Jahren ohne WhatsApp und
ich habe da nicht eine einzige Einschränkung in meinem Leben wahrgenommen.
Ich empfinde das zunächst einmal als besondere Bereicherung und als ich jetzt
kürzlich mal dazu gefragt wurde, wurde mir auch irgendwie so klar,
wenn ich das hinkriege, als jemand, der als Sprecher des CCC.
Relativ viele Kontakte zu allen möglichen Leuten halten muss,
insbesondere Journalistinnen, der beruflich nicht bei einem festen Unternehmen
arbeitet, sondern als Berater da auch tausend Kontakte hat.
Wenn ich das irgendwie hinkriege, ohne WhatsApp klar zu kommen,
dann kriegt es wahrscheinlich jede andere Person auch hin, weil sie nur ihr
normales, soziales Umfeld da mal hinbewegen muss.
Und das ist gar nicht so schwer. Zum Beispiel, wenn man dann sagt,
okay, wie kriege ich das denn hin?
Das war beim ersten Dit, der berichte ich gleich, von der am Sonntag ja war,
das war ja der erste Sonntag im Monat.
Dann fragten Leute so, ja, jetzt habe ich hier, ich habe jetzt Signal installiert
und meine Nachbarin auch, aber die schreibt mir einfach weiterhin auf WhatsApp.
Was mache ich denn jetzt? Ja, genau, dann gehst du einfach hin und stellst die
Notifications bei WhatsApp aus und abends, bevor du schlafen gehst,
guckst du einmal in WhatsApp rein und schreibst den Leuten, ach so,
sorry, ich habe dir ja gesagt, schreib mir auf Signal, ich lese das hier nicht mehr.
Wenn du das nächste Mal eine Antwort zeitnah haben willst, schreibst du mir halt da.
Und rucki zucki kriegst du halt diese kritische Masse, die du ja erstmal für
dich nur in deinem unmittelbaren sozialen Umfeld brauchst, hin.
Also bei mir ist es ja auch passiert und zwar war das nicht ich alleine mit dem Evangelium,
sondern das hat sich dann einfach so ergeben und vor allem merken die Leute
ja auch, dass diese alternativen Systeme häufig auch tatsächlich besser sind.
Also ich zum Beispiel muss wirklich sagen, wenn ich so ein WhatsApp sehe,
allein von der grafischen Oberfläche kriegst du ja schon Zustände.
Und ich denke, es ist kein unmögliches Unterfangen, da mal ein paar Sachen zu ändern.
Aber es ist eben vor allem ein soziales Projekt viel mehr als ein technisches.
Deswegen muss man es eben oft machen und in kleinen Schritten machen.
Und wir als CCC haben uns zum Ziel gesetzt, naja, wir helfen den Leuten dabei.
Wenn es technische Fragen oder technische Probleme gibt, wenn man sich jetzt
zum Beispiel in so einer neuen App orientieren will.
Also ich denke auch tatsächlich, dass es jetzt ein bisschen anspruchsvoller
ist, sich im Fediverse mal auf Anhieb zurechtzufinden, als irgendwie bei Facebook oder so.
Aber das haben ja sehr viele Menschen vor uns geschafft, das finden auch sehr
viele Menschen, auch nach uns werden das noch schaffen.
Und deswegen haben wir als CCC gesagt, okay, wir rufen dazu auf und das haben
wir jetzt in sehr, sehr vielen CCC-Ehrfass letzten Sonntag auch gemacht,
dass die Leute kommen mit ihren Fragen und dann helfen wir ihnen.
Gehen wir ihnen den richtigen Rat, was weiß ich, was sind denn so deine Informations-
und Kommunikationsbedürfnisse?
Wie deckst du die denn jetzt zum Beispiel im Fediverse ab oder mit welchem Messenger
kannst du die am besten kannst du dir am besten deinen Bedürfnissen da begegnen.
Interessant war auch.
Ich war jetzt im Berliner CCC beim DIT.
Da waren irgendwie so insgesamt, würde ich sagen, über den Zeitraum so 40 Personen.
Jetzt auch die von uns mitgezählt.
Und da waren aber nicht so viele CCCler. Und die meisten, die da waren,
die hatten jetzt quasi schon so erste Schritte gemacht und haben sich eher darüber
ausgetauscht, okay, wie kann man das denn jetzt eher in die Breite tragen?
Wie kann ich denn jetzt anderen das zeigen und die davon überzeugen.
Das heißt, es hat wirklich einen Nerv getroffen und viel Anklang gefunden und
war wirklich ein echt cooler Austausch.
Ich bin da hingegangen und hatte natürlich auch Sorge, dass eventuell da vielleicht
gar keiner ist. Kann ja auch sein.
Und dass einfach niemand diesem Angebot und diesem Aufruf folgt.
Das war zum Glück nicht der Fall und jetzt haben wir direkt für den nächsten
Termin schon konkretere Pläne und viel gelernt.
Löblich. Obwohl eigentlich es ja die Firmen und Unternehmen sind,
die die größten Independence-Bedürfnisse hätten.
Ja, also ohne Frage. Es heißt ja auch bewusst nicht irgendwie digitale Souveränitätstag
oder sonst was. Das ist halt einfach nur mal so ein bisschen.
Und das ist auch wirklich das, was Marc-Uwe und ehrlich gesagt auch mich am
meisten besorgt, ist halt wirklich
dieser Einfluss auf das, was Menschen sehen, denken und wahrnehmen.
Und der Einfluss dieser sozialen Medien ist halt wirklich, wirklich enorm.
Und wenn du jetzt mal nur darüber nachdenkst, dass so ein Mensch,
also nehmen wir einen durchschnittlichen Menschen, guten, braven Bürger in einer
kapitalistischen Demokratie.
Er arbeitet schön seine acht Stunden plus halbe Stunde Mittagspause.
Und schläft acht Stunden. Das heißt.
Irgendwie 16,5 Stunden Aufmerksamkeit sind gebunden und es geht dann eigentlich
nur noch um siebeneinhalb Stunden Aufmerksamkeit, freizeitliche Aufmerksamkeit,
die der Mensch frei verfügbar hat.
Und was er da in dieser Zeit wahrnimmt, der Mensch, wird sein Gehirn beschäftigen.
Und es wird unweigerlich prägen, was dieser Mensch für relevant und wichtig hält oder nicht.
Das wird beeinflussen und prägen, welche politischen Werthaltungen und inhaltlichen
Priorisierungen sich in diesem Gehirn ergeben.
Das sind richtig, richtig nachhaltige, starke Einflüsse, wenn du da jetzt,
sagen wir mal, irgendwie in deinem Screentime-Ding stehen hast,
von den siebeneinhalb Stunden freier Aufmerksamkeit, die der Tag dir gönnt,
verbringst du drei auf Facebook und Instagram.
Und wenn du jetzt noch überlegst, du bist ein Konzern, der das nicht nur bei einer Person hat,
sondern bei einem signifikanten Anteil der wahlberechtigten Bevölkerung,
dann wird dir irgendwann klar, was da für eine Macht in der kleinsten Algorithmusänderung ist.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass das den Leuten mal klar wird.
Ich habe ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass sich das sozusagen jetzt in alle Bevölkerungsschichten
sofort rumsprechen wird.
Zumal ja auch die Bevölkerung selbst dabei ist, sozusagen diese Netze zu ihren
Zwecken zu nutzen unter denselben Aspekten.
Es sind ja jetzt nicht immer nur die großen bösen Geheimorganisationen,
die auf einen einprasseln und staatliche Akteure,
sondern es ist ja auch in der Gesellschaft schon so verbreitet,
auf andere Leute da Einfluss zu nehmen und es ist einfach nicht fein.
Aber es stimmt schon, die sozialen Medien sind definitiv der Ort, der am meisten schmerzt,
wenn es um die Independence geht denke ich, kann man auch mal drüber nachdenken
und zwar gar nicht mal so jetzt aus so politisch moralischen Gründen allein,
sondern auch mal aus so ganz,
praktischen Gründen, dass man vielleicht auch so seine Datenwelt und seinen.
Organisationsbereich, den man so auf dem Computer so ausbreitet und eben auch
im Internet, dass man da schaut, wo liegt eigentlich mein Scheiß?
Von welchen Accounts bin ich abhängig? Also was zum Beispiel mich fast noch
mehr schmerzt, ist, dass so viele Leute dann einen Gmail-Account oder einen
Facebook-Account haben.
Und den nicht nur jetzt benutzen, um da dann was zu posten oder da Mail zu verschicken,
sondern um sich bei anderen Diensten dort einzuloggen.
Also wenn euer Login auf allen möglichen Diensten, die ihr nutzt,
ein zentraler Dienst ist und der läuft rogue, der wird dann,
keine Ahnung, von Trump kassiert und sagt so, ja hier Leute,
die das Wort Antifa mal geschrieben haben oder nur Anti, die dürfen sich jetzt
auch nirgendwo mehr einloggen.
Das ist jetzt Gesetz in den USA. Das ist ein bisschen hypothetisch,
aber ihr wisst ja schon, was gestern noch eine Hypothese war,
kann morgen schon in der Zeitung stehen.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was ich auch empfehlen würde,
was man mal zurückschneidet.
Also ich habe das, ich glaube, ich bin mir relativ sicher, ich habe glaube ich nur,
einen einzigen Dienst überhaupt, den ich benutze, wo ich mich mit einem Account
eines anderen Anbieters autorisiere.
Ein einziger.
Und das aber auch nur, weil es da keine andere Möglichkeit gibt.
Und ich den aber trotzdem benutzen will, aus guten Gründen. Und ansonsten mache ich das nicht.
Ich benutze sehr wohl.
So Dienste wie Amazon, um so ein bisschen Backup-Daten abzuwerfen.
Ich benutze Dienste wie Dropbox, einfach weil sie für mich praktisch sind.
Aber das sind auch schon so Sachen, wo ich immer drüber nachdenke. so, ah, was habe ich da?
Wie sicher ist das noch? Welche Alternativen bieten sich mir,
die die gleiche Funktionalität anbieten?
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Schmerzt auch so ein bisschen, weil man eigentlich bei jeder Transition gucken
muss, okay, was verliere ich jetzt an Funktionalität?
Oft ist man ja auch aus gutem Grund bei diesen Diensten.
Aber es ist vielleicht einfach mal so als Tipp, macht euch eine Liste.
Macht eine Tabelle auf, Notizdokument, was auch immer und fangt dann mal an,
jeden Tag, wenn ihr euch irgendwo einloggt oder wo ihr irgendwie bewusst ein
Programm, ein Dienst startet, schreibt es einfach mal auf, nicht so als Log,
wenn ihr euch eingeloggt habt, sondern diesen Dienst benutze ich.
Einfach nur so, dass man mal eine Liste hat, mit was benutzt man eigentlich alles.
Ich habe einen Wohnungswechsel hinter mir und da musste ich dann auch so,
welches Unternehmen hat eigentlich meine Adresse?
Oder ich musste mal...
Das ist der Grund, warum ich nicht mehr umziehe.
Wem sage ich da Bescheid? Also wer weiß das alles, wo ist es irgendwie wichtig
auch, dass das da die richtige Adresse ist, weil ich dann sonst wieder in andere Probleme laufe,
bei Banken und Auswahl, dann kommen Ausweise und dann irgendwann widersprechen
sich so die Daten. ist ja auch ein Problem.
Also Independence, nicht nur jetzt Independence von den USA,
sondern überhaupt auch mal so ein bisschen Independence von dieser ganzen Datenlage
und dazu ist einfach auch wichtig für sich selbst so ein.
Empowerment, also so eine Ermächtigung herbeizuführen, dass man überhaupt erstmal
den Überblick hat, was benutze ich eigentlich?
Und dann, deswegen empfehle ich auch gleich so eine Tabelle zu nehmen,
dass ihr euch da mal Spalten machen könnt mit, wo logge ich mich,
womit ein, wie wichtig ist das, habe ich da Daten rumliegen oder ist das nur
so etwas, was ich so casual benutze?
Und dann kriegt man glaube ich auch selber einen ganz guten Blick dafür,
ist das jetzt zu viel? Habe ich das überhaupt noch im Blick?
Was kostet mich das? Ihr könnt natürlich dann auch mal schauen,
wenn das so Bezahldienste sind.
Es ist ja auch so, dass einem diese ganze digitale Welt auch hier ein bisschen
Geld ausnimmt und da rausnimmt und Netflix hier und Cloud-Speicher da und Server hier und VPN dort.
Da kommt dann auch einiges zusammen und auch das kann glaube ich dazu führen,
dass man einfach erstmal auch sich selbst dazu ermächtigt, dann in Zukunft auch
entsprechende Entscheidungen zu fällen,
dass man einfach weiß, ah okay gut, also das ist hier so und so viel Prozent
meiner digitalen Geschichte oder wenn ich darauf verzichte, habe ich ja auch noch das.
Und dann auch mal so Daten vielleicht mal runterholen, mal ein Backup einrichten,
dass man mal was wegspeichert, dass die Fotos, die eigentlich nur online sind,
dass sie vielleicht auch mal auf irgendeiner Festplatte landen.
Und wenn es nur einmal im Jahr ist, dass man sich da was ins Regal legt,
das sind alles glaube ich solche Schritte, die dazu führen können,
dass man dann auch bewusster im Netz agiert und auch bewusster mit seinen eigenen
Computing-Ressourcen umgeht.
Also so mal wieder seine ganzen Daten zusammenzusammeln ist auf jeden Fall eine,
Auch eine sehr schöne Übung habe ich gerade hinter mir. Ich habe ein neues Laptop in Betrieb genommen.
Mit coolen Stickern drauf.
Schon ein richtig schöner, cooler Sticker drauf. Obwohl, ich habe tatsächlich
auf Empfehlung eines Kollegen mir ein Framework gekauft.
Sehr schönes Gerät.
Ein bisschen,
ein bisschen eher so, ein etwas anderer Style als meine anderen Geräte.
Aber macht auf jeden Fall sehr viel Spaß, haben ein paar sehr kluge Sachen und
kann man gut dran rumschrauben.
Und ich brauchte, also das Einzige, was mich daran etwa, was halt sehr nachteilig
ist, hat halt so einen Verbrennerprozessor.
Aber genau deswegen, den brauchte ich halt.
Auch da dann mal sich so in seine komplett neuen Umgebungen einzurichten und
mal so ein DIT-Gerät zu bauen, ist auf jeden Fall auch eine sehr schöne Übung.
Genau, mach das mal. Das Entscheidende ist, man will ja eigentlich nicht jetzt
irgendwie so eine blöde Sekte gründen, sondern es geht einfach darum,
das mal so ein bisschen entspannt und pragmatisch anzugehen.
Um mal zu sagen, okay, wo kann ich denn mal hier irgendwie ohne großartiges
Stress, ohne dass es mir irgendwie weh tut, mal so langsam so einen Umstieg einleiten.
Und ich glaube, da gibt's halt wirklich, du musst es wirklich sagen,
aus den Gesprächen, das ist viel, viel, viel weniger problematisch,
als Leute sich das vorstellen.
Dass es überhaupt problematisiert wird, finde ich an einigen Stellen schon fast lustig.
Und.
Der Teil, das, was es eigentlich schwer macht, ist nicht etwas Technisches, sondern was Soziales.
Und um den sozialen Teil muss man uns schon immer selber kümmern.
Ansonsten auch wirklich viele nette Leute da gewesen. Interessanter Austausch.
Und kann ich nur empfehlen. Und wenn ihr auch beim DIT mitmachen wollt,
müsst ihr nur ordentlich posten, wie eure Erfahrungen sind.
Und dann kann man das langsam in die Wege leiten. Mir fällt da auch nichts anderes
zu ein, weil, ich meine, nochmal, die anderen Plattformen sind auch nur in diese
Rolle gelangt, weil wir sie nutzen.
Und wir sind auch die, die deren Wert ausmachen. Das ist ja das andere Faszinierende.
Was für Milliarden die umsetzen, weil wir sie nutzen.
Ja, kostenlos. Also das ist ja auch immer so wirklich so faszinierend,
es ist so abgedroschen zu sagen, wenn du nicht dafür bezahlst, bist du das Produkt.
Aber es ist so.
Ich habe in meinem Leben Google keinen einzigen Cent gegeben und die meisten
anderen Leute auch nicht.
Ich weiß, du bezahlst für YouTube, ich nicht. Ich gucke aber auch kein YouTube.
Klar, du guckst kein YouTube.
Ich gucke kein YouTube, nee.
Nee, wirklich nicht. Mir fehlt die Zeit dafür. Wir können jetzt gemeinsam hier
in diese YouTube-History gehen.
Weiß nicht, ich glaube vor drei, vor anderthalb Monaten hat mir mal jemand ein
YouTube-Video empfohlen.
Ja, also da kann ich ja nichts dafür. Wenn du so beschäftigt bist mit deinen
Porn-Sides, dass du noch nicht mal für YouTube-Zeit hast, ist ja auch traurig.
Nee, Tim, ich bin, du kannst dir das gar nicht vorstellen, aber wie du weißt,
mache ich Dinge in meinem Leben.
Wirklich?
Es tut mir leid, dass ich keine die Zeit fehlt.
Aber ich vermisse das auch nicht. Ist auch in Ordnung.
Du gibst Google Geld, aber auch dieses Geld reicht nicht für die Milliarden,
die die jedes Jahr einen Gewinn machen. Dieses Geld verdienen die woanders.
Und auch bei die Infrastruktur für YouTube bereitzuhalten, das Geld,
was diese Menschen oder was diese Konzerne anhäufen, es ist ja wirklich schwindelerregend.
So, dann,
war ja noch so ein Kongress.
Hat stattgefunden. Der 39. Chaos Communication Kongress.
39 C3 in Hamburg.
Ja, wir waren da und haben auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise daran teilgenommen.
Aber wir haben beide mal einen Podcast auf der Bühne aufgenommen.
Ja, da in diesem Sendezentrum bin ich mal vorbeigegangen, weil ich letztes Jahr
auch schon beim CT-Podcast Passwort, aber das ist ja eher so eine Randerscheinung.
Was haben wir denn an Talks zu empfehlen?
Du warst bei der Freakshow, das ist dein einziger Beitrag gewesen.
Ja. Es ist nicht mein einziger Beitrag gewesen.
Aber mein einziger Podcast-Beitrag gewesen. Ein einziger aufgezeichneter Beitrag.
Genau, ansonsten habe ich ganz viel telefoniert.
Ich dachte, du hättest YouTube geguckt.
Auf Kongress, bitte dich.
Ja, also ich denke, es gibt ein paar Talks, die man mal erwähnen kann.
Sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit bereits. Wenig überraschend hat ja der Talk von Corey Dr. Rowe erhalten.
Nicht ganz unverdient. Er ist ja derjenige, der diesen schönen Begriff der Entgertification
in die Welt gelassen hat und ist ja auch bekannt als Kritiker,
der Zustände im Netz, auch vieler dieser Zustände, die wir hier schon beschrieben haben.
Dazu holte er dann eben auch auf dem Kongress nochmal aus und hat eigentlich eine,
ja Ich würde sagen, unterm Strich fast schon,
nach dem richtigen Adjektiv, optimistisch will ich jetzt nicht sagen,
aber eine emphatische Herleitung gebracht, dass ja die ganze Scheiße,
in der wir da gerade rumwarten,
auch die Gelegenheit bietet sich sozusagen der amerikanischen Umklammerung im Netz zu entledigen.
Ja, also insbesondere spricht er ja quasi über die Gesetze,
die die Umgehung von Schutzmaßnahmen illegalisieren.
Also Gesetze, die Jailbreaking und quasi illegal machen.
Gesetze, die, wenn eine, er nimmt ja viele Beispiele, Traktorhersteller hier, John Deere oder so,
die dann quasi Seriennummern an ihren Ersatzteilen haben und der Traktor funktioniert
halt nur, wenn er irgendwie von einem John Deere-Techniker,
repariert wurde.
Oder das Beispiel, was wir letztes Jahr beim Kongress hatten mit den Zügen.
Und im Rahmen der Freihandelsabkommen sorgen die USA immer dafür,
dass diese Regeln zum Schutz der geistigen Eigentumsrechte,
mit in den Einigungen drinstehen.
Und seine Argumentation ist, naja, diese Freihandelsabkommen habt ihr ja,
oder diese Handelsbeziehung habt ihr ja, damit es keine Zölle gibt.
Und jetzt gibt es aber Zölle. Mit anderen Worten.
Braucht ihr eigentlich auch nicht mehr das zu achten und könntet jetzt Ökonomien
entstehen lassen, beispielsweise um das Jailbreaking zu.
Hör mal auf, er überspringt da so ein bisschen, dass die Europäische Union das
ja quasi sogar schon gemacht hat, dass es eben alternative Stores geben muss,
auch für Apple-Geräte oder so.
Und wenn ihr das tut, dann könnt ihr quasi diese Abhängigkeiten brechen,
diese Abo-Fallen und Zwänge, die die Plattformen mit sich bringen.
Und nicht nur das, ihr könnt quasi daraus eine quasi Firmen entstehen lassen
und die Geräte alle wieder befreien.
Jedenfalls könnt ihr die USA da treffen, wo es ihnen wirklich wehtut,
nämlich quasi an dem, wo sie einen im Prinzip gefangen nehmen in Plattformen und in Abhängigkeiten.
Und sagt also im Prinzip, diese Abhängigkeiten haltet ihr ja durch eure eigenen
Gesetze aufrecht, die ihr erlassen habt, um von den USA nicht mit Zollen gegängelt
zu werden. Aber das tun sie ja jetzt nun mal.
Also solltet ihr irgendwie überlegen, wo ihr diesen Schaden auch wieder gut macht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das so eintreten wird, wie er es sagt,
aber er weist zumindest mal auf einen sehr interessanten und wichtigen Schmerzpunkt hin.
Und es wäre vielleicht schön, vielleicht kommt Friedrich Merz ja nach längerer
Prüfung der Maduro-Situation zu dem Ergebnis,
dass er sich jetzt ein anderes OS auf sein Android flasht.
So wer weiß. Nein, aber,
es ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Analyse der Abhängigkeiten und wie wir
eventuell diese, an welchen Stellen wir diese Abhängigkeiten vielleicht auch
nochmal selber entforcen für die USA.
Gegen unsere eigenen Interessen.
Tipp zu dem Vortrag, stellt man die Abspielgeschwindigkeit auf 75%.
Findest du?
Ja, fand ich, musste ich unbedingt machen. Er redet wirklich extrem schnell
und vor allem leider auch sehr, also nachvollziehbar, aber trotzdem,
Man kann dem Talk schneller folgen, umso mehr man über Amerika,
amerikanische Innenpolitik, Namen, Personen, Firmen und so weiter weiß.
Aber ich fand den Talk deutlich konsumierfähiger mit 75 Prozent.
Aber das muss jeder selber wissen.
Interessant. Ich hätte ihn lieber schneller gestellt, weil er zwar schnell spricht,
aber sagen wir mal, inhaltlich kommt über längere Strecken nicht viel Neues,
sondern immer nur Beispiele für den gleichen Punkt.
Für dich, Linus, für dich.
Okay.
Dann haben wir, ja, wir wollten eigentlich unten anfangen. Jetzt fangen wir doch oben an.
Ja, ist einfacher. Auf media.ccc.de. Der meistgesehene Vortrag ist eine völlige
Überraschung, ehrlich gesagt, von Christian Fuchs, Eva Hoffmann und Martha Ruth.
Die Heartbreak Machine, Nazis in die Echo Chamber.
Die haben so ein soziales Netzwerk so eine Datingseite für,
für Weiße zum Erhalt der weißen Rasse die weiße Rasse ist ja allen halben bedroht
wir kämpfen ja wirklich man sieht gar keine mehr man sieht gar keine mehr und so und deswegen,
gibt es da irgendwie Datingseiten, die sich dem Erhalt des weißen Genoms verschrieben
haben und das sogar international machen.
Also im Prinzip sagt der Christian Fuchs auch in dem Vortrag,
so ist es eigentlich unüblich, dass Rassisten sich über Landesgrenzen hinaus bewegen.
Aber in diesem Fall haben sie quasi, da schlucken sie ihren Ausländerhass mal
runter, um die Rasse zu erhalten.
Naja, da haben sie ein bisschen analysiert und es gibt noch am Ende,
habe ich mir sagen lassen, einen,
überraschenden Höhepunkt.
Dann hatte ich gerade schon erwähnt, Marc-Uwe Kling war da und hat aus dem neuen
Kängurubuch gelesen, das bald erscheinen wird,
die Känguru-Rebellion und die Idee des Digital Independence Day ist natürlich
auch eine Idee des Kängurus.
Und damit endete dann auch diese Lesung, dann kamen sehr viele Leute von den
unterschiedlichen Airfas des CCC noch mit auf die Bühne und sprachen,
ihre Unterstützung des Digital Independence Days gezeigt.
Einer davon war auch ich. Das war sehr lustig, weil wir so, ich hatte dann so
gesagt, ja okay, lass uns mal irgendwie eine Dreiviertelstunde vorher treffen,
damit wir da noch alle rein können.
Das war in der Pause, der Saal war bereits eine Stunde vorher.
Mindestens eine Stunde vorher, war er dicht, ja, ja.
Hab ich auch gemerkt.
Die ganzen DIT-Supporter, die irgendwie am 4.
Januar Aktivitäten angeboten hatten und für die ich eigentlich dachte,
die kriegen jetzt die Premium-Plätze, mussten alle hinter der Bühne rumhängen.
Das hat mir dann echt sehr leid getan.
Aber viele haben sich dann einfach hinter der Bühne hingehauen und haben Stream
geguckt und waren happy. Okay.
Ebenfalls habe ich heute erst gesehen von Q. Mizzell und.
551724 Maya Böck. Also laut Bio ist diese Nummer...
Ein wichtiges Handle.
Sehr schöne Analyse. All my Deutschland Tickets gone.
Fraud at an industrial scale. Die haben analysiert, wie als Fraudster Deutschland
Tickets verkauft haben, weit unter Preis.
Und wie die an diese Tickets gekommen sind.
Gab es halt irgendwelche Webseiten, konntest du ein Deutschland Ticket für 15 Euro kriegen.
Und dann fragst du dich das ist aber erstaunlich, wie geht das denn,
und ja, das ist auch wirklich wieder, da weißt du dann wieder da holt dich die
wohlige Gewissheit, dass du in Deutschland bist weil wie haben die diese Deutschland-Tickets geholt.
Naja du kannst natürlich in Deutschland per SEPA-Laststrift-Mandat bezahlen
und weil der Deutsche natürlich trotzdem sofort sein Ticket haben will,
wird dem natürlich ein Ticket ausgestellt,
bevor die Lastschrift abgebucht ist. Bevor die Lastschrift durchgegangen ist.
Und dann hast du dann kann das Unternehmen, was dir dieses Deutschland-Ticket
verkauft hat, und das sind ja sehr viele, das kann ja jeder Verkehrsverbund
in Deutschland, das sind sehr, sehr viele, dann kann der das Ticket löschen,
Und macht das sicherlich auch in seiner App.
Ja? Aber das signierte Ticket ist halt immer noch gültig vor jedem Prüfgerät
in diesem kompletten Deutschland-Ticket-Verband.
Und die haben halt keine Revocation-Listen gehabt. Oder zumindest keine,
die sie sinnvoll genutzt haben.
Und so konntest du eben, Deutschland-Ticket kaufen, kriegst es sofort,
dann platzt die Lastschrift, weil du halt eine Fake-I-Bahn angegeben hast,
die halt den Validity-Check passt.
Und ja, und dann fährst du damit durch die Gegend und jedes von diesen Prüfgeräten
wird das Ticket nach wie vor für echt halten.
Scammer 15 Dollar, Verkehrssystem 0.
Da kommt ganz schön was zusammen.
Da kommt ganz schön was zusammen. Und dann weißt du auch, warum die Dinge auf einmal teurer werden.
Da sind also wirklich, die haben dann so Zehntausende gefunden.
Und dann in einer sehr eingeschränkten Stichprobe von nur da geprüft,
nur in dem Zeitraum und so weiter und so fort. Und auch nur da,
wo es kontrolliert wurde.
Und dann haben sie noch auch einen Verbund oder ein Unternehmen gefunden.
Die haben dann direkt den Private Key zu ihrem Zertifikat verloren.
Ja, Deutschland. Also es ist einfach Deutschland.
Das ist wirklich nicht zu fassen.
Wir hatten, wir gehen mal so ein bisschen im, bleiben mal so im politischen,
politisch relevanten Bereich, weil es ja wirklich sehr, sehr viele Vorträge
und Podcasts und so waren.
Den CCC-Jahresrückblick haben Konstanze, Khaleesi, Matthias,
Erdgeist und ich gemacht.
War, glaube ich, auch dieses Jahr ganz gut.
Wir waren besser vorbereitet, haben ein paar entscheidende Themen und Punkte untergebracht.
Dann gab es auch einen sehr schönen Vortrag eher technischer Natur über Schwachstellen
in GPG-Implementierungen.
Das ist glaube ich schon eher ein technischer Vortrag aber weil GPG ja dann doch so relativ,
weit verbreitet ist und immer als besonders toll gilt dafür waren es dann doch
eine ganze Reihe an Schwachstellen die da gezeigt wurden,
von denen eben einige auch peinlich sind und bei einigen dann auch der Umgang
der Autoren oder des Autors, damit peinlich,
Arne Semsrott Best of Informationsfreiheit auch wirklich ein Feuerwerk dieses Jahr ist.
Es ja eigentlich immer.
Ja, hat jetzt in weiten Strecken auch nichts mehr mit Frag den Staat oder Informationsfreiheit
zu tun nein an einigen Stellen, aber es ist schon wirklich cool,
was das Team von Frag den Staat da so,
alles macht und das war sehr unterhaltsam präsentiert.
Ich glaube, ich hatte es schon angekündigt, Zentrum für politische Schönheit
hat über den Adenauer und den Walter Lübcke Memorial Park gesprochen.
Natürlich auch sehr, sehr sehenswert. Und,
Aber weil wir über beides, glaube ich, hier schon ausführlich gesprochen haben,
und wir davon ausgehen, dass ihr den Vortrag eh schaut, habt ihr den Link in den Shownotes.
Du kannst auch was sagen.
Ja, ich habe noch nicht so viele Talks nachgeschaut. Ja, also so für den gepflegten,
Hackbedarf war ja auch so, das eine oder andere dabei.
Sehr unterhaltsam fand ich den Talk über das Hacken von Waschmaschinen.
Einfach weil es mal wieder so ein
Ort ist, wo man normalerweise vielleicht nicht hinguckt und es gab halt,
zwei Jungs, die es einfach mal gemacht haben, die sich also ihre eigenen Waschmaschinen
angenommen haben, die mal komplett reverse-ingeniert haben, festgestellt haben,
wie alt die Technologie ist, die da drin zum Einsatz kommt.
Spoiler, sehr alt. Also da fühlte ich mich glatt in meine Jugend zurückversetzt. So 6502 und sowas.
Das kann man sich auf jeden Fall mal anschauen.
Und wer vielleicht Interesse hat, auch seine unsmarte Waschmaschine zu versmarten,
da haben die dann auf jeden Fall auch noch so einiges im Angebot.
In der selben Kategorie gab es dann auch noch den schönen Bastelvortrag,
der ein FitHub 611-Tisch-Telefonapparat der alten Schule, also noch mit Wählscheibe,
in ein Bluetooth-Headset verwandelt hat, mit Batteriebetrieb.
Also ich würde sagen, das hat auf jeden Fall auf einer Party geschlafen.
Zumindest für eine bestimmte Weile noch einen sehr hohen Coolness-Faktor.
Da solltet ihr auch mal drüber nachdenken. Auch sowas ist ja wichtig im Leben.
Also der ganze Apparat kriegt dann eine neue Platine und Batterien.
Und man kann halt wirklich mit der Wählscheibe, mit dem Apparat in der Hand,
ohne dass irgendwelche Kabel rausgehen, quasi sein Handy damit fernbedienen
und wählen und dann Leute anrufen.
Und das dürfte für den einen oder anderen Head-Turner reichen.
Endlich wieder ein ordentliches... Endlich so ein Autotelefon wie Kommissar Schneider. Endlich.
Hallo, Schneider.
Nico Semsrott hat Prüf vorgestellt.
Auch eine Initiative in allen Bundesländern.
Und zwar jeweils in der Landeshauptstadt am 2.
Samstag im Monat. Ihr merkt, wir füllen jetzt so langsam mit diesem Kongress eure Wochenenden.
Und zwar für den Prüfantrag aller Parteien, die im Verdacht stehen,
verfassungsfeindlich zu sein, zu demonstrieren.
Das ist wirklich sehr schön, weil natürlich der Vortrag handelt sehr viel vom Prüfen.
Und ich glaube, mein Moneyquote aus dem Vortrag war im Prinzip so,
es widerspricht der Idee von Deutschland auf eine Prüfung zu verzichten,
die man theoretisch vornehmen kann.
Und das finde ich wirklich, hat er eigentlich sehr recht.
Also irgendetwas nicht zu prüfen, obwohl man es kann, das ist undeutsch.
Das ist wirklich undeutsch. Dabei sind wir in der Lage, damit wirklich jeglichen
gesellschaftlichen Fortschritt aufzuhalten.
Und ausgerechnet hier wird es mal nicht genutzt.
Ja, ich glaube, die Formulierung müssen wir nochmal gucken.
Weil du sagst, gesellschaftlichen Fortschritt aufhalten.
Könnte man die mal voranbringen durch eine Prüfung.
Das könnte ein Grund sein. ähm,
Es gab einen schönen Hack auch von, also, das ist jetzt auch so eine Hackkategorie.
Sei es die Waschmaschine, sei es der Rollstuhl,
in alles werden halt irgendwelche Smart-Technologien eingebaut und in der Regel von Leuten,
die besser bei der Ursprungstechnologie geblieben wären,
nämlich zum Beispiel eine Waschmaschine oder einen Rollstuhl zu bauen und dann
natürlich entsprechende Fahrlässigkeiten oder Fehler verbauen,
die eben bei diesem Rollstuhl zum
Beispiel auch zu ganz interessanten Funktionserweiterungen geführt haben.
Den Rollstuhlvortrag haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt.
Ich habe ihn doch jetzt gerade erwähnt.
Ja, okay, also jetzt haben wir ihn erwähnt.
Jetzt haben wir ihn erwähnt, ja.
Also es gab auch so einen Vortrag.
Bianca Kassel hat mal das erste Jahr nach dem EPA-Debakel zusammengefasst.
Auch das findet ihr in den Shownotes. Und Konstanze Kurz hat zusammen mit Franziska
Görlitz über die ganze Palantir-Situation gesprochen.
Einerseits, was ist das überhaupt für eine Software? Andererseits, was sind das für Leute?
Aber natürlich gibt es auch die Alternativen. Findet man jetzt die Alternativen cool?
Was hat das? Und die Franziska Görlitz ist bei der GFF, wenn ich mich nicht
täusche und kann natürlich auch jeweils einordnen, dass das nicht nur ästhetische Fragen sind,
die sich da stellen, sondern eben auch vor allem handfeste rechtliche Fragen.
Ich habe den Vortrag nicht gesehen, aber von Leonard über die Drohnenkriege,
ich glaube, den muss ich mir als nächstes anschauen, weil es auf jeden Fall,
ein spannendes Thema ist.
Hatte ich ja glaube ich auch in der letzten Sendung schon mal.
Versucht euch noch den Jahreswechsel vor Kongresszeit mit zu ruinieren.
Und was ich durchaus auch sehr wichtig fand,
ist AI, Agent AI Spy von Utbaf Tiwari und Meredith Whitaker,
die ihr ja auch kennt, weil sie schon mal in einem Podcast zu Gast war,
die Präsidentin der Signal Foundation.
Und worüber die gesprochen haben, ist.
Die Frage, also postulieren wir es kurz, AI ist jetzt das neue Ding.
AI ist die Technologie, die diese ganzen Big-Data-Mengen potenziell noch besser verwerten kann.
Und deswegen kommt das jetzt überall rein. Und AI ist die Technologie, die geeignet ist,
User-Interfaces noch sehr viel individueller und zielgerichteter zu gestalten.
Also wer schon mal was versucht hat, oder wer sich noch daran erinnert hat,
was zu googeln, statt Chat-GPT zu fragen oder bei Google eine Antwort von Gemini
zu bekommen, weiß, wie unangenehm,
denkaufwendig das teilweise war, eine Antwort auf eine spezifische Frage zu finden.
Und es ist natürlich sehr viel
schöner, wenn man die Antwort einfach bekommt und sei sie auch falsch.
Und was damit aber natürlich einhergeht ist, dass jetzt eigentlich eine der Kampf.
Eröffnet ist, darüber, wo jetzt diese AI ist,
also wird man, wird es, wird google.com als Anfang des Internets abgelöst, ja,
könnte ja sein, oder löst eventuell eine AI das Internet ab und das Web ab,
Dass man im Prinzip sagt,
es gibt jetzt einfach eine AI
und ihr könnt gerne eure APIs dafür bereitstellen und dann wird unsere AI,
wenn ihr genug bezahlt, auch eventuell von diesen APIs Gebrauch machen,
aber ansonsten ownen wir jetzt das Fenster zur Welt.
Und dann ist aber die Frage, wo läuft das denn?
Und während natürlich die, wenn du jetzt eine webfokussierte Perspektive hast,
würdest du natürlich sagen, okay, ich versuche eine neue Webseite zu etablieren
oder ich bin jetzt bei Google oder in dem sozialen Netzwerk.
Wenn du aber ein Betriebssystem vertreibst, dann wirst du natürlich sagen,
pass auf, meine AI kommt natürlich in das Betriebssystem.
Und die wird bitteschön die Apps erfassen, die hier noch auf meinem Betriebssystem
installiert werden dürfen.
So hat es ja Microsoft mit dem Recall gestartet und hat gesagt,
wir machen einfach alle paar Sekunden ein Screenshot und werten die aus.
Was natürlich ein sehr plumper erster Schritt war.
Apple hat ja schon seit, ich weiß nicht wie lange jetzt die Apple Intelligence
Pläne schon bekannt sind, wo sie eben sagen, ja, eure Applikationen sagen uns
dann bitte Intents und dann werden eure Applikationen von unserer AI fernbedient.
Oder Funktionalitäten eurer Apps werden von unserer AI dann bedient.
Das heißt, es gibt jetzt.
Also dieser Kampf oder dieser Wettkampf, dieser Wettbewerb ist jetzt da und
Google mit Android und Apple mit iOS und Microsoft mit Windows werden alle versuchen,
die AI zu sein.
Weil dann ist so dieser, ich meine, dann ist das, was wir gerade,
wo wir über den Ditch sprachen, wo wir sagten, ja, umziehen ist irgendwie komplizierter.
Wenn alle deine Daten die gar nicht mehr wirklich zugänglich sind und dein Interface,
Also wenn letztendlich Webseiten und Apps nicht mehr da sind,
sondern du eine AI hast, mit der du arbeitest, die aber jetzt zum Beispiel deine
Daten auch nicht freiwillig hergeben wird, das sind ja ihre Daten, ist ja völlig klar,
dann reden wir natürlich nochmal von einem ganz anderen Vendor-Login-Effekt.
Aber der Vortrag beginnt eigentlich damit was Signal nämlich für Probleme hatte
mit der Signal Desktop App in Microsoft Windows dafür zu sorgen,
dass diese Screenshots nicht das Privatsphäre Versprechen von Signal brechen,
weil wenn du sagst, hier ist ein verschlüsselter sicherer Messenger und dein
Betriebssystem macht die ganze Zeit Fotos davon und speichert die auf der Platte
und lässt die von der AI analysieren hast du halt ein,
ärgerlich Ja, ärgerlich. Und.
Gelöst haben sie das Problem am Ende damit, dass sie quasi das genutzt haben,
was zum Beispiel so eine Videoplayer-App macht, nämlich DRM.
Sie haben das als DRM gefleckt und dann schließt es nämlich Microsoft Recall aus.
Aber das ist natürlich wirklich erstens eine sehr plumpe Herangehensweise,
die Microsoft da gewählt hat und auch eine entsprechend sehr hemmsärmelige Verteidigung
gegen eine sehr dumme Maßnahme.
Aber die Zukunft wird natürlich eher sein, dass du als App-Entwickler eigentlich
sich die Frage stellt, wird dir überhaupt das Recht eingeräumt,
dich durch eine AI-Verwertung der Datenbestände, die du als Applikation.
Hältst und verwaltest, dich dagegen zu wehren.
Ist das ein Grundrecht, das du vielleicht als App-Entwickler hast oder nicht
hast, wenn du für eine solche Plattform codest?
Und das wird da, das führen die beiden dann halt aus, dass quasi als Developer
jetzt auch mal Rechte brauchen,
sich gegen invasive AI-Betriebssysteme mindestens jetzt ein Opt-in zu haben
und nicht automatisch einfach da reingeschlaucht zu werden.
Und das sind natürlich die Schritte, die hier jetzt passieren.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr gut analysiert und höchst relevant.
Karelisi und Markus Reuter haben nochmal das Chat-Kontrolle-Thema zusammengefasst
und wie es jetzt weitergehen wird.
Es ist eine nie endende Geschichte und deswegen haben die beiden auch einen Vortrag dazu.
Die Analyse der Kindersmartwatch von Nils Rollhausen wurde auch sehr viel gelobt.
Ehrlich gesagt, auch wieder ein Murks wird verkauft und dann wird er eben aufgemacht.
In diesem Fall aber eben etwas, was eher spezifisch zum Tracking von Kindern gebaut wurde.
Und kannst dir ungefähr vorstellen, welche Konsequenzen dann Schwachstellen
haben, die man in so etwas unter Infrastruktur dahinter findet.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Das sieht man auch schon auf dem Screenshot hier.
Ja.
Und das Schlimme ist, so viel kann ich glaube ich sagen, also aus dem Themenbereich
gab es mehrere Einreichungen.
Das ist quasi ein, jetzt geht es wieder genau nicht nur um diese eine Smartwatch
für Kinder, sondern das ist dann wieder so ein Massenproblem.
Und dann kommt erst, wir gehen ja gerade von oben nach unten durch,
statt, wie wir es eigentlich geplant hatten, von unten nach oben.
Ten Years of Dieselgate von Felix Domke und Carsten Burger.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube, er hatte ich auch schon vor dem Kongress empfohlen.
Felix Domke hat also die Geschichte ging irgendwie so los, dass er irgendwie
ein VW hatte und irgendwann halt mal,
die Firmware von der ECU gedumpt hat und die analysiert hat und dann halt da
drin halt am Code diese ganzen Erkennungen.
Von bin ich auf einem Prüfstand, wie viel AdBlue verwende ich jetzt,
wie konfiguriere ich als Engine Control Unit diesen Diesel.
Und er hat es halt nicht irgendwie so, das Auto verhält sich unterschiedlich
oder so, oder es gibt Anlass oder irgendwie komisch, das Auto hält im Straßenverkehr
nicht wirklich die Prüfwerte ein, die es auf dem Prüfstand hat,
sondern er hat halt im Code wirklich.
So Sachen gezeigt, wie, naja, sobald das Lenkrad mehr als 30 Grad gedreht wird,
ist die Abschalteinrichtung aus. Warum?
Naja, weil du auf dem Prüfstand halt nicht so weit lenkst. Und das ist halt,
also wirklich, wo du dann wirklich ganz klar sagen kannst, das kannst du nicht
mehr erklären mit irgendwie einem Bug oder einem Fehler, sondern hier ist halt
gezielt Prüfstanderkennung.
Oder auch so, wenn du dann die Graphen siehst, wo quasi in welchen Bereichen,
sich etwas verhält, Zum Beispiel, dass das Auto spätestens nach der Dauer eines
Prüfstands auf jeden Fall volles Pfund Abgase rausbläst.
Und alle diese Analysen, ich weiß nicht, wie viele ECUs und Hersteller er da
analysiert hat, und er hat ja, alle diese Analysen waren ja dann auch immer
in Gerichtsverfahren relevant und so.
Und das ist wirklich richtig, richtig krass, weil du im Vortrag eben die Zusammenhänge
von diesen Abgasreinigungen lernst, Vorgaben, Prüfungen,
dann aber noch irgendwie Hardcore eine ECU nach der anderen reversed und den
Code analysiert und gezeigt, was macht der jetzt hier.
Das ist wirklich at its finest.
Den kann ich wirklich wärmstens empfehlen.
Weil es ja dann eben noch, neben, dass du so viele technische Komponenten hast,
dann eben einer, würde ich sagen, der größten Skandale.
Naja, was ist das jetzt? In welchem Bereich ist das? Was der Automobilbranche,
des Verbraucherschutzes, des Umweltbetrugs?
All of the above.
Einmal alles. Das ist wirklich ja, das ist so einmal alles und es setzt wirklich
so, ich finde, es setzt wirklich so Maßstäbe für Congress-Vorträge,
weil es halt so technisch so unglaublich breit und gesellschaftlich so irrelevant ist.
Ja, super Arbeit und den empfehle ich wärmstens.
Und wer hat Angst vor dem Neutralitätsgebot? Den hat vor allem Anne Roth sehr
gelobt, die die Heraldin für diesen Vortrag war.
Aber es wird ja sehr viel darüber gesprochen,
wer jetzt alles irgendwie neutral sein müsse oder wer neutral zu sein habe oder
wessen Gemeinnützigkeit man mal prüfen müsste wegen mangelnder Neutralität.
Und die beiden Vortragenden, Hanna Voss und Vivian Kube, betrachten das halt
mal aus der juristischen Perspektive.
Gibt es überhaupt ein Neutralitätsgebot für Lehrerinnen, für Beamte,
für Angestellte im öffentlichen Dienst,
für Bundestag, für Regierungsmitglieder und für gemeinnützige Organisationen
und wie gestaltet sich das denn?
Und in der Regel ist es eben, also es ist in jedem Bereich natürlich anders,
die rechtliche Grundlage ist eine andere, aber es gibt halt kein Neutralitätsgebot.
Es gibt es einfach nicht.
Es gibt zumindest nicht so, wie es öffentlich diskutiert und in der Regel von der AfD behauptet wird.
Natürlich gibt es dann was weiß ich sowas wie Mäßigungsgebot für Beamte und
üblicherweise kannst du dir merken.
Parteipolitische Neutralitätsgebote gibt es, klar aber gleichermaßen sind alle,
die irgendwie zu parteipolitischer Neutralität verpflichtet sind in der Regel auch zu,
auf die freiheitlich-demokratische Grundordnung verpflichtet und naja,
das ist auf jeden Fall sehr schön auseinandergenommen und gerade weil,
sage ich mal, mit diesen,
Also das ist ja nicht, das ist ja jetzt wirklich ein relevantes Thema.
Wenn die AfD da irgendwie ihre Meldeportale für Lehrer hat, die nicht neutral wären,
wenn gemeinnützige Organisationen jetzt demnächst auf den Prüfstand kommen,
weil ihnen vielleicht mangelnde Neutralität vorgeworfen wird oder eventuell
sogar der Eindruck entsteht,
dass man neutral sein müsse,
als gemeinnützige Organisation, dann lohnt es sich, sich damit mal inhaltlich
genau auseinanderzusetzen.
Nicht, dass die AfD wirklich von Neutralität spricht. Sie meint ja nur mit.
Das ist ja was gegen uns gesagt worden. Und das geht ja nun mal gar nicht.
Genau, die haben uns kritisiert, das geht so nicht.
Die sagen ja hier offen, was wir sind.
Ja. Ja. Das könnt ihr so nicht machen, ne?
Ja, das fand ich auf jeden Fall sehr. Der wurde auf jeden Fall auch,
vielseitig gelobt, dieser Vortrag. Schauen wir mal, was haben wir denn noch?
Was sehe ich wahrscheinlich? tagelang weiter Talks auflisten.
Aber ich glaube, Linus, das reicht doch erstmal, oder?
Echt? Wir müssen ja...
Wir haben noch so viele Sendungen dieses Jahr.
Ja.
Die können wir alle nur mit Kongress-Talk-Erwähnungen können wir die füllen.
Das wird da an Zeit sparen.
Okay, aber ich dachte, wenigstens alle, die bei uns schon mal in der Sendung
zu Gast waren, erwähnen wir noch.
Aber das wäre dann wiederum noch eine Menge.
Eben.
Alright.
Dann höre ich ja jetzt schon auf. Man kann das sehr schön,
so durchlaufen lassen.
Es gibt das ja auch als RSS-Feed.
Aber nicht so als Fernsehen, ne?
So ein Kongress-Stream, der die ganze Zeit einen Talk nach dem anderen einfach laufen lässt?
Doch, sollte eigentlich kein Problem sein. Hier ist ja ein RSS der letzten 100,
also es gibt unterschiedliche RSS-Feeds,
und die solltest du ja ganz einfach in einem Podcast-Player deiner Wahl abonnieren
können und dann müsste der Player deiner Wahl das auch einfach nacheinander abspielen.
Ja, da musst du ja alles runterladen. Ich rede jetzt von so einem Streaming-Dienst, der das tut.
Aber ist egal, war jetzt nur so eine Idee. Gibt es, glaube ich,
in der Form nicht. Aber wäre vielleicht mal was für die Zukunft.
Ja, ich war auch heute ein bisschen verwundert, dass nicht einfach nach einem
abgespielten Video das nächste kommt.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach, weil das Dark-Patterns sind,
Tim. Die sind alle nur da und nicht auf der Plattformzeit.
Musst du YouTube nehmen, dann hast du das.
Ja, genau, du guckst media.ccc.de auf YouTube und zahlst 10 Euro dafür.
Ich gucke das halt einfach mit meinem Flayer hier.
Ja, schön.
So, jetzt wären wir eigentlich schon fertig, aber ich muss noch ihr Merkurper
sagen, weil darauf hätte ich eigentlich schon vor einem Monat hinweisen können.
Hätte ich auch gewollt, hätte ich nicht die E-Mail verlegt und jetzt ist...
Du hast die E-Mail verlegt?
Ja.
Hast du die ausgedruckt und dann auf den falschen Schreibtisch gelegt oder was?
Ich drücke doch meine E-Mails nicht aus. Ich bin doch, will doch dafür,
dass der Planet überlebt. Ich bitte dich. E-Mail ausdrucken.
Das macht man nicht. Das steht doch immer unten drunter. Nicht ausdrucken.
Damit Bäume und so, weißt du?
Ja.
So, worüber rede ich denn eigentlich? Ich rede von einer Ankündigung von Jugendhakt.
Wir kennen die Organisation, die kümmert sich um die Jugend,
dass die hackt und tut das üblicherweise ja in einem Wochenendformat.
Also man lädt Jugendliche ein, die sich dann zu Gruppen zusammenschließen,
um dann ihrer technischen Kreativität freien Lauf zu lassen.
Und dann wird das Ganze auch mit so Mentoren betreut und es sind immer ganz
erkleckliche, nette, hilfreiche Veranstaltungen, wo einfach diese Initiative
einfach gefördert wird.
Ihr macht jetzt einfach mal was, ihr hackt jetzt einfach mal was runter.
Jetzt gibt es was Neues und zwar wird jetzt mal so Long-Term-Support bereitgestellt.
Das heißt, man kann sich jetzt bewerben mit einem konkreten Projekt und das
findet dann nicht mal so an einem Wochenende statt und dann war es das,
sondern das kann hier irgendwie auch ein Jahr lang laufen.
Da muss man sich also mit einem konkreten Projekt anmelden und dann,
wenn man da halt ausgewählt wird und quasi ein Projekt macht,
was hier ins Spektrum passt, also mit Tech und Code,
gesellschaftliche Probleme lösen, das ist so ein bisschen der Untertitel an dieser Stelle.
Egal, ob das jetzt so Alltagsprobleme sind oder was auch immer.
Genaue Beschreibung findet ihr auch auf der Webseite.
Also kann Hardware sein, kann eine App sein, kann was auch immer sein.
Also das liegt dann ganz bei euch und die Chance, die man da halt hat,
ist, dass man dann eben Unterstützung erfährt,
da so zwei Mentorinnen auch noch zur Seite gestellt bekommt,
das Ganze auch in einem bestimmten Rahmen finanziell gefördert bekommt etc.
Ja, allerdings Anmeldefrist 11. Januar 26.
Oje.
Ja, also ihr habt jetzt...
Noch nicht mal eine ganze Woche Zeit. Und es tut mir auch sehr leid,
dass ich das jetzt erst erwähne, aber noch leider hätte es mir getan,
wenn ich es jetzt gar nicht erwähnt hätte. Also habe ich es jetzt erwähnt.
Alter, 14 bis 21 Jahre und wenn ihr es also noch schafft, euch jetzt zu bewerben
mit einem Projekt, dann wisst ihr auch schon Ende Januar, ob das dann dabei ist oder nicht.
Ja.
Link in Bio.
Ich habe, glaube ich, bei der,
Vorstellung des Dit gar nicht auf den,
Terminkalender hingewiesen. Das würde ich an dieser Stelle gerne noch einmal
nachholen, denn der das kann ich jetzt zum Ende noch sagen. Am Ende machen wir immer Termine.
Unter termine.di.day werden jetzt gerade 84 bevorstehende Veranstaltungen,
angeboten. Nicht alle an ersten Sonntagen im Monat.
Und da gibt es eine ganze Reihe an Organisationen, die da schon mitmachen.
Und ich kann das wie gesagt aus eigener Erfahrung, die Erfahrungen waren gemischt.
Es gab auch Orte, an denen halt echt wenige aufgetaucht sind.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie klar hast, du in Berlin mit einer kleinen Ankündigung
eine höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit.
In anderen Städten muss man das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen länger im Voraus
ankündigen und in der Lokalpresse oder was auch immer da die besten Wege sind. Aber.
Das ist, das war nett. Ja, und das ist eine, da findet man coole Leute und kann
irgendwie schön abnerden und coole Tipps kriegen.
Das kann ich euch nur nahelegen, auch mal so ein Event zu machen.
Und wenn ihr kein Event macht, dann könnt ihr eben am Tage selber von euren,
heroischen Umzügen berichten.
Und das ist natürlich auch ein Problem, wenn das dann, das veräppt ja dann,
ne, irgendwann bist du ja ausgezogen.
Da musst du natürlich trotzdem weiter mitwirken.
Und so tun, als wärst du nochmal umgezogen. Als wärst du rückfällig geworden.
Hat schon wieder mit dem Rauchen aufgehört. Weißt du sowas?
Und die Seite wird aber betrieben. Das finde ich ganz cool. Das ist echt ein,
ganz nettes Open-Source-Projekt von Samuel vom Chaos Computer Club Flensburg. Sehr schön.
So, jetzt aber Schluss hier.
Jetzt aber Schluss.
Genau, Leute, wir wünschen euch ein nicht nur ein frohes, sondern auch ein glückliches neues Jahr.
Das können wir alle ganz gut gebrauchen, glaube ich, Glück.
Und ja, wird sicherlich wenig gute Nachrichtsjingles geben, aber wir hoffen
darauf, dass es ein paar gibt.
Ansonsten begleiten wir euch auch weiterhin durch die Apokalypse, wie ihr es gewohnt seid.
Ja.
Machen wir.
Werden wir versuchen, ja.
Wir versuchen euch durch die Apokalypse. Das klingt richtig optimistisch jetzt. Richtig.
Wenn Apokalypse, dann mit uns.
Genau. Mit uns ist Apokalypse einfach besser.
Oh Gott, wir müssen Schluss machen. Tschüss Leute, bis bald.
Wenn man das moralferne Geschäftsgebaren des autokratieaffinen Weltfußballverbandes
problematisch findet, ist man dann in der Anti-FIFA.
Ist man dann mein Handy vibriert. Natürlich unterbreche ich sofort auf brutalstmögliche
Weise meine Gedanken, um die wahrscheinlich unwichtige Nachricht zu lesen.
Dann bin ich aber doch überrascht. Wir müssen uns trennen, hat das Känguru geschrieben.
Hä, was? Erwidere ich eloquent.
Als nächstes bekomme ich ein Video. Du warst mal so klar und fokussiert und
schnell. Das mochte ich an dir.
Aber dann habe ich festgestellt, dass du dir echt alles notierst,
was ich tue, was ich mir ansehe, wie lange ich es mir ansehe und dass du meine E-Mails liest.
Das ist super creepy. Du bist voll der Stalker und versuchst mich komplett zu
überwachen. Das fühlt sich nicht geil an.
Und wozu das alles? Damit du anderen rumerzählen kannst, was ich mag und was
nicht? Ich will das nicht mehr. Wir müssen uns trennen.
Das Känguru kommt ins Wohnzimmer. Verstehst du? Fragt es.
Äh, sag ich. Ich nenne das Video Goodbye Google.
Also.
Ich muss gestehen, dass ich ganz kurz dachte, du redest von mir. Von dir?
Na, von wegen alles notieren und dann rumerzählen.
Sag ich, aber wann warst du mal klar fokussiert und schnell?
Zugegeben, sag ich, aber wofür soll das Video gut sein?
Das Video ist teiltes dit oder auf gut Deutsch des dud.
Na, pass auf. Die halbe Welt wird immer mehr zu einer digitalen Kolonie der USA.
Und jetzt, wo etwas mehr als die Hälfte der Amis jubelnd in die Wildwasserrutsche
Richtung Faschismus gesprungen ist, stellt sich manch einer die Frage,
ob das nicht unter Umständen doch ein paar Problemchen verursachen könnte.
Beispiel gefällig, Trump hat Sanktionen gegen den internationalen Strafgerichtshof
verhängt. Voll der Superschurken-Move, by the way.
Und deshalb hat Microsoft dann mal kurz den E-Mail-Account des Chefanklägers
deaktiviert, Auch Paypal, Amazon, Kreditkarten, alles geht für die betroffenen Personen nicht mehr.
Je mehr US-Tech benutzt wird, desto erpressbarer wird die Welt, sag ich.
Genau, mal ganz abgesehen davon, dass, wie ich bei anderer Gelegenheit schon
erwähnt habe, Big Tech durch sein digitales Quasimonopol bei Werbung und Verkaufsinteraktionen
massiv Geld aus der Realwirtschaft absaugt und noch nicht mal ernsthaft Steuern dafür zahlt.
Aber, frage ich, jetzt kommt doch hoffentlich ein Aber. Das Känguru springt
auf den Wohnzimmertisch, ballt die Faust und ruft in feinstem Roland-Emmerich-Pathos,
Wir werden nicht schweigend in der Nacht untergehen.
Wir werden nicht ohne zu kämpfen vergehen. Heute feiern wir gemeinsam unseren
digitalen Independence Day.
Das Beuteltier hüpft kichernd wieder vom Tisch. An jedem ersten Sonntag im Monat
ist DIT der digitale Independence Day.
Oder auf Deutsch der digitale Unabhängigkeitstag, der DUT.
Ist das so? Frech. Noch ist das nicht so, gibt das Känguru zu.
Aber es könnte doch bald so sein.
Und was passiert am DIT? Am DIT nimmt man sich Zeit, diesen einen Wechsel durchzuführen,
von dem man schon sehr lange weiß, dass man ihn machen könnte.
Es mangelte nur am Moment, es auch zu tun.
Also zum Beispiel weg von X zu Mastodon, von WhatsApp zu Signal oder Threema,
von Google zu Ecosia oder DuckDuckGo mal in die Mediathek gucken und dafür Prime
kündigen, von Amazon zur lokalen Buchhandlung oder wenn man nicht ohne großen
Versandhändler klarkommt, dann halt zu Otto, Konrad oder einem beliebigen anderen
altdeutschen Vornamen.
Das Ziel ist einfach weniger Abhängigkeit, weniger Monopol, weniger Überwachungskapitalismus.
Aber, melde ich mich zu Wort, keine Panik, der Dit soll kein Sekten-Scheiß werden.
Es geht nicht um ein digitales Reinheitsgebot.
Der Ansatz ähnelt eher moderner Kindererziehung.
Nicht schimpfen, positiv verstärken.
Aber es ist meiner Aufmerksamkeit nicht entgangen, dass du selbst Accounts bei
fast allen relevanten Social-Media-Plattformen hast.
Ja, aber auch, weil du findest, dass man sie nicht kampflos rechtsradikalen
Faktenfeinden überlassen darf, verstehe ich.
Wer aus irgendwelchen geschäftlichen oder familiären oder aktivistischen Gründen
auf irgendeinen Big-Tech-Kram nicht verzichten kann, dem darf ich Plus Eins empfehlen.
Plus eins heißt, nutze erstmal zusätzlich auch eine der Alternativen.
Zum Beispiel für dich, alles auch auf Mastodon oder sonst wo im Fediverse.
Wer dein Zeug sehen will, aber keinen Bock mehr auf Big Tech hat,
findet dort ein Zuhause.
Aber wage ich einzuwenden. Ich weiß, dass wir eigentlich wie beim Klima nicht
nur individuelle Verhaltensänderungen brauchen, sondern vor allem große politische,
systemische Veränderungen. Ich nicke.
Dafür braucht es jedoch öffentlichen Druck, fährt das Känguru fort.
Und der DIT wäre quasi eine monatliche digitale Demonstration für mehr digitale Unabhängigkeit.
Ein wiederkehrender Anlass für unsere eventgeilen Medien über das Thema zu berichten.
Es macht überdies auch mehr Spaß, wenn man den Polygarchen zusammen den Rücken kehrt.
Man rebelliert quasi gemeinsam.
Das Kängur liegt gegen die Zustände. Und ich glaube, es ist hilfreich,
wenn man entspannt rebelliert.
Damit die Leute nicht überfordert sind.
Man könnte sogar so Wechselpartys organisieren, wo die Leute sich treffen können.
Also in echt. Crazy Vorstellung, ich weiß.
Aber der Legende nach sollen das Menschen bis in die Kabelzeit hinein gemacht
haben. Gerade sonntags in der Frühe.
Da hatte sich schon die Kirche gedacht, da haben die Leute doch nichts zu tun. Korrekt.
Könnte auch Veranstaltungen in der Disco machen und nennt das Independence, schlage ich vor.
Warum nicht? Na jedenfalls, sich jeden ersten Sonntag im Monat bei einer Sache
ummelden, das ist machbar.
Und damit es mehr Spaß macht, könnte man eben so witzige Trennungsvideos posten. Oder Memes.
Und natürlich darf man sogar damit angeben. Hashtag Didit.
Oder Hashtag Dude gemacht.
Ich bin dabei. Gut.